hey
everybody welcome enemies
should we plan something to say like
should we have an opening tagline like
most
podcasts do do they no oh they don't oh
they but they usually like go like
hey everybody or they have some kind of
way to open it so it's not as awkward oh
i feel like
that should be like dan you know how
they have like gilman for like regis and
kelly like i feel like there needs to be
like a gilman
we need an announcer
[Laughter]
it's gotta be really dumb top good
afternoon
are they friends today or are they
enemies here's your favorite frenemies
ethan and trisha right thanks that is
really good
dan you want to try that jesus come on
get hit us with that
are they friends or are they enemies
today
tune in to find out are they friends or
are they enemies today
tune in to find out on today's episode
of frenemy
i like that that's wonderful that was
good you did that i like cringe doing it
and then like having something that was
a really good idea though
okay maybe we'll get an announcer maybe
you'll be the answer well he's he's the
only one here so i mean like
your dogs are humping each other okay
first of all what is you about that
you're a sex worker
that these are dogs why are they hungry
they're brothers
first of all they're not related by
blood you know step porn is like the
most popular genre
and then second of all it's a it's a
shredder's alpha we have so much to talk
about today
i know so much from tick tockers fake
faking pranks jeffree star is back with
hereby j joel olsteen's niece emailed me
dr phil called me and wanted me to be
fake on the show
gay burgers your weight loss valentine's
day my weight gain i look more like
kevin smith than adam sandler today
kevin smith looks good
that's funny it's i've gotten so fat
like i literally like oh me and
announced they only have like similar
body types so even his clothes don't fit
me like i was buying all his clothes on
ebay
and like now as i got literally i'm like
okay let me just be real about it let me
just buy kevin smith's old clothes i
mean
he's skinnier than me now congrats kevin
smith can you buy kevin smith's old
fat clothes see how they fit me yeah
that'd be kind of cool
oh yeah i feel like he's down with
podcasts maybe
did you well nevermind you don't really
care about that
how do you know because i know every
time i bring up them you like don't care
so well we have more than that to talk
about first of all
there was a lot of drama on our show of
surrounding one of our cast members that
said something about
about the situation with david and i
also want to talk about david a little
bit before we move on
oh it should be continuing we can talk
about him for 10 minutes every episode
because
there's like actual crimes being
committed and nobody cares like
literally nobody cares it's so
it's so annoying i've seen tick talkers
like see people on tech talk are pretty
woke about this
being like if this was a girl like this
that thing if this was a girl talking
about essay like you know everyone would
be like
he'd be like in jail like it's a crime
and like nobody cares and they keep
praising this one
every episode we should talk about david
dobrik i'm so down because
he's doing some shitty [ __ ] like so
first of all
let me let me back up a little bit and
say that um
i want to first of all
apologize to you i should not have
allowed that
to occur i thought ah excuse me
getting out the that's not the tourettes
that's the gerd that's the gerd
did it look like yeah because it was
very loud inside that one was tourette's
okay
it's hard to tell the difference you
know
a b i we had arguing this been arguing
this backstage
and i was like wow this you know this is
i thought it would be just like
entertaining to debate it but
i should have been more considerate
knowing that it would have triggered you
so i and then and then on the other hand
i also should apologize
i do apologize to ab because i
first of all the amount of [ __ ] he got i
knew he would get
some i thought maybe it would be like
funny [ __ ]
but it turned out being like really
intense mean
death threat did you script what he had
to say no did you point him in the
direction of what to say
no so you shouldn't have to apologize
what he said is what he said he got
backlash and you know
one i was surprised you guys did it not
because it like to trigger me it's just
like one thing because you just
interviewed
nick you're interviewing all these
victims and then you're like okay
somebody who wasn't there to defend him
but at the same time he said that those
were his words so yes i get that you
guys got backlash for it or whatever but
like so
don't say ignorant [ __ ] you're not there
don't try and say that person's lying
which is essentially what he did that
all three of us are [ __ ] lying that's
exactly what he insinuated i know but i
should have known
i should have like we were having those
debates backstage and i should have
not put him i should have said like
these are these are better off camera
yeah i was definitely surprised because
you're like inviting like victims onto
your show of like essay and stuff like
that and then you're just like then
you're like oh let's have someone debunk
what they're saying like that was a
little shocking well
well to be fair we didn't we didn't we
were very
we were debating it wasn't like oh this
is a perspective okay
no defense but that being said other
aspects not
people who are victims of these things
don't be like oh debate like you could
debate it well he gave out cars he did
this try and like make it paint him in a
good light without having to debunk that
we're a liar you know what i totally
agree
and i and i failed everybody or invite
someone but also
that was just ignorant and what he said
the amount of ignorance of it
like literally had me saying red usually
i don't care and i'm usually like not
but that triggered me so much because
for years i've been getting those
comments from david stands well trisha
was along with it trisha did this and
hearing that is so [ __ ] awful like
how dare you like i've heard that for
years so to hear
someone else just be ignorant as [ __ ] i
was like wow like this person
i don't have zero respect for me i still
do and i have no forgiveness and my
my thought process was i agree this is
the kind of comments that
you get and so my thought process was
like let's bring it out in the open
and and then deal with this kind of
thing because i feel like me and ila
pushed back on it a lot
for sure and so we were like okay well
this is how there's a lot of people that
feel this way
so let's talk this out so i thought
those who weren't in the situation
nobody
i agree with you but i'm saying that if
we put this conversation forward maybe
we can convince
people to that they shouldn't think the
way he does i don't need to convince
anyone i share my truth just like
they're sharing their truth
this helps none of us like everybody
said from nick to me to seth like it
helps none of us if anything it makes us
look obsessive as people call me oh
she's obsessed with that
that's not what i mean i mean people who
are presenting that
argument that a b did i wanted to
give people a response to it so the
people who watch our podcast can think
oh
what abe thinks isn't true okay so what
he was saying
was not his opinions you're saying no
what's his opinions but i was saying
that
putting the debate out in front i
thought was a good for people to watch
and learn what we had to say in response
to it
yeah it was great because people saw
what it is
no it was and then as soon as he gets
backlash he does an apology
it's like that's i hate that [ __ ]
too it's like it's you know it's not
sincere
you said what you said and because you
got backlash it's like now i'm like let
me apologize and i accept an apology
i'll accept it all day long but it shows
what idiots those people are that are
blindly defending david that were not in
that situation
of seth how dare he say seth is lying
says a person of color is feeling racist
and you're gonna tell him he
like don't feel that way that's such
[ __ ] it infuriated me to a whole
different level and i don't care if
people think we are hard on him or
whatever that's ignorant stupid comments
i've been hearing those for [ __ ]
years so the part about eight first of
all
i want to say abe is a great guy people
were sending him death threats and like
harassing
every day i get death threats every day
for being fat for being whatever people
send me death threats like
it's you put yourself online like don't
be on camera don't have your own youtube
channel like
he made jokes of it on tick tock being
like about to get canceled y'all like he
you knew exactly what was coming and
what was happening it was so gross to me
i didn't like it
it's my fault it's my fault okay well i
don't i don't i don't think so that
like maybe it was to have him on the
show period but his opinions were that
and that showed his true colors and that
was disgusting so
i agree i thought it was weird you guys
had him off yeah like what the hell i
i know that's his true colors don't even
want that around me like i don't want
it's like shane saying he didn't believe
me i don't want people like that
i'm telling you my truth and my story i
don't lie i have everything i say has
been proven and backed up on camera like
it's just it's
it's facts there's nothing else to say
so i mean yeah i know you like are but
you're backtracking with it now
the problem is he's my employee and like
i care about him
as a at his well-being so i have to like
he's he's a good guy you know and it was
like
i think in the moment he got caught up
in trying to make these like
impassioned arguments mm-hmm and then
afterward he was like oh
that's ignorant and the initial reaction
not obviously not death threats
obviously but it's just like
when you're ignorant like that and you
say ignorant stuff like trying to say
like well
she she did this she was okay she
flirted with david so she just she
deserves this even though she said it
was uncomfortable and like all this
stuff like that she deserved that can i
say like
in a good way i think the debate and
everything and all that happened
i do feel like he's seeing things
differently
is he or do you just get backlash i
think he is okay
i didn't get an apology from him
he did a generic apology because people
were like hating on him because people
loved abi and now they hate him they
didn't engineer i didn't get anything i
need to text from him i see him all the
time
i work with him i talk with him he never
texted me sorry like
i think he would if he had a threat he
thought he thought he could follow him i
follow him because he can message me he
could do
yeah there's plenty of ways he know you
could reach out to me like there's so
many things so
it's fine i mean it's fine it to me it
was
i think he learned his lesson to just
not be stupid online like but that's his
real
beliefs and that's it showed it showed
and it was disgusting
i'm sorry it's my fault i take
responsibility for the whole thing
so that happened which the part that
really annoyed me though
is like first of all we did this what i
thought the interview with seth was like
i was blown away by seth's interview he
was so articulate
he was so impassioned he told his story
so well
and the details of it blew me away every
time right
and then when it comes out first of all
everybody's talking about
a b and then the second time everybody's
talking about
that i was too much of too hard on ab
people were so
upset about that whole dynamic that like
nobody cared about what seth said
yeah and david got off again yeah always
i do want to remind people that
ab didn't actually what do you say
essay yeah that's the good way to say it
so you don't get ding dong
i like that that's what they do on tic
tacs the essay i saw that i was like sa
yeah yeah all of my episodes with them
got demonetized
which sucks because less people see it
but anyway
um this guy was saying i was literally
essayed
that sounds like it's fantastic fifth
grade
oh oh i'm saying like essay
he was literally essayed by david and
jason
twice and somehow they're evading the
responsibility yet again
like nobody like dude 90 of the comments
were about either me
or ab and i was like damn again that i
[ __ ] up because
the focus should be on seth yeah amy
should never have been on that show like
at all like have an apology like on your
own time or whatever but like
that was so sad like because hearing
that like i knew that was happening
because
as i was telling you that was like a
month after i started dating jason i
remember telling him i wasn't like
i thought it was weird for a number of
reasons mine was more like oh you're
going to kiss this guy like
that was what was bothering me more so
than i didn't know that he wasn't like
consenting to it and
even the stuff with the girl is like oh
i had no i had no idea like hearing it
from him i was like wow this is like
so messed up and then also just i don't
know not to recap the last episode but
then also you know like saying you're
gonna pay him money and then didn't it
and like you know no i do want to recap
it because people prepare
i want to re-emphasize what i heard all
your episodes are recapping like
previous episodes but
i mean still no this stuff excuse me
that was all well you're right part of
it was recap the seth was original
no and that was like crazy to me to like
see because we're all
keep in mind me and big nick and seth
and everyone we never looked we weren't
cross so like all our stories are like
similar but like no one ever crossed
paths with each other and big me and big
nick
obviously don't like each other i mean
he said like to shout out her own agenda
which is like what is my age
i have no agenda i got kicked out of
this group everyone thinks i'm obsessed
with these people there's no agenda like
what was my agenda this was truth this
is all it is
but um we all have like the same like
similar stories of like not consenting
asking things to not be put in the thing
and then once we say we're uncomfortable
getting exiled from like even a
friendship with any of them or whatever
um thing that got an apology seth didn't
even like the fact oh they ghosted him
they couldn't even pick up his phone
call like he was trying he called him
for like he was trying to reach him
before the interview because he didn't
want to have to do it
and they ghosted him people like i don't
know i don't know i'm
so confused how people are so how this
is not a bigger deal
the fact that like no nobody picked the
story up
right somebody comes out incredibly he
not credibly it's fact he's on camera
twice being essayed by david nobody's
picking it up no like van none of these
[ __ ] big magazines
not a keemstar it's like they're so
funny are they they're either they're
afraid of david's
fans because or or i don't i don't i
literally don't know what it is club
thing
because he's like the cool guy that
nobody wants to make fun of of course
and he's like
you know doing brand deals with chipotle
and tesla and like all these things so
people are like oh he's like this power
right also just like how are you so it's
like you know
it's like when pewdie look first
pewdiepie messes up it's like a media
frenzy
david is he's literally he like made
this guy move to another city in shane
yeah it's insane and nobody's right i
can't
my mind i just i can't when i was
hearing that i was like wow this is
going to be a huge story
he's on camera being essayed yeah and
say
and like but like everyone like i had it
that he didn't know like everyone knew
about this it's like so crazy it's so
crazy to me
and the fact that he like said he was
like uncomfortable and asked him to take
videos down and they weren't taken down
like it's insane to me
so yeah the craziest things to me was
that he refused to take the videos down
when he asked him and he offered to pay
him money and seth said something really
interesting he's like that's when i knew
they weren't really my friends
yeah and then the other thing was during
the second beef jerky during this
elaborate ruse to set him up to make out
with jason again
the contract offered him 2 500 bucks
which he was planning on receiving that
money and when it was done david refused
to give him the money
right the dog's [ __ ] with you they're
a lot
yeah they're fun um yeah i
i don't know i don't know it's like it's
so crazy i don't know david will get
away with like everything but i
people have come forward to you the same
person who emailed me you had emailed me
another
guy said he was a victim of jason yeah
unwanted
stuff and um and that it was on camera
and stuff and i've heard this from
numerous people
and girls and it's like all i say is
they always can you share
can you put this out there like i know
this and all i say is like you guys have
to put out like your own stories like i
can't be the one there are
underage girls that said that they were
fed alcohol like all this stuff if you
have your own story but same thing when
dom like
there's enough out there if no if this
isn't enough then nothing is but people
are scared that's what i'm saying is
like
these people like the guy that emailed
you and then i asked i know him
personally like he's someone in the
sphere and he had he shared that same
story it's like
you have to say something because if
you're comfortable but like if you don't
say it then like we
i can't share it for you because like
it's not my story well i'm just gonna
look like
i'm obsessed with david i can't put
everyone's story out because it it takes
away the credibility from everything
i don't know though i disagree i know
you said that and i totally get it
because this is like obviously people
are going to just
yeah people are not going to take me
seriously if i just turn it into the
david giving like a platform to people
like i'm shocked
seth shared that story because he got
like he got didn't get as much attention
last year when he was trying to talk
about this
and big nick as well like i'm shocked
that they came forward because big is
still on good terms with david and it's
like at least you're giving people like
a safe platform where they feel they're
backed by a big creator which is you
because going against david alone you
just like it just gets lost in the void
and you get
[ __ ] on it yeah it's awful so there's so
many
stories i've heard over the years and it
just sucks like this one girl got
essayed by dom a person in the vlog
squad at vidcon she was underage and
he forced himself on her and and they
swept under the rug
and it was proof and like i think i
think dom apologized
i don't think that cuts it sorry
the fact that david hasn't even
apologized to him or acknowledge it to
like
it's insane it's so insane he doesn't
have to acknowledge any of this [ __ ]
publicly it's like crazy
because nobody's holding them
accountable literally and this time i
thought for sure it would stick
but there's a few things that oh
actually there is somebody holding him
accountable
who the foot soldiers watch this
don't don't do that look at his wiki
feed rating and tell me that we don't
hold accountability here on this show
foot soldiers
assemble david dover cut a 4.8 or
something like stellar like that
what's his writing now read it read it i
literally can't see i have like the
worst eyes ever
1.37 how is david dobrik's content so
allowed on
on youtube i don't understand that like
how are those
trisha i feel like you glossed over the
fact that we tanked his wikipedia like
the things that i didn't consent to are
still up there him scaring me in the
shower
like not so okay that's what i want to
get onto now
not funny because like seth asked him to
take stuff down that like racist [ __ ]
and like stuff that i asked him
and he said let me pay you and seth's
like what the stuff with tana like i
like
i don't want that [ __ ] out there like
okay i have so
a lot of the stuff you claimed has been
resurfacing
over the past few days and i've been
watching these and i'm like holy [ __ ]
there's like video evidence of all the
[ __ ] you're saying
is it okay with you if i open this yeah
of course yeah okay so
here's one i snuck into their hotel room
you told an anecdote about how he
you and jason were having uh let's say
relations
and he so tell why don't you tell me you
were there
tell me what happened are you talking is
this the shower clip yeah i snuck into
their hotel room literally the thumbnail
because you asked me if there was video
of this
like it's literally the thumbnail and
title oh yeah yeah wait i have a picture
of the thumbnail here i want to show it
because the even the thumbnail i was
like what the [ __ ]
yeah so here's the thumbnail
jesus not very flattering image of you
who does that sound like with the
thumbnails here on the front of these
podcasts i don't do like come on
i think his head next to you they like
blow me up and it's like you want them
to shrink my
your head they just don't put me equal
anyways
um so it says i snuck into their home uh
hotel room surprise
this is the last vlog i'm in before the
tana stuff went down so this is like the
last cuz i did not i was not comfortable
with this i did not want this in there
either
so tell me what happened tell me the
situation it was what when does it come
out is around christmas time right
when was the this is just a re-upload oh
here it has
what is the original one down the day
after christmas so the day after
christmas so i remember this wait is the
original one that's a good question let
me see
i have the link i thought it was yeah i
thought the original one was still up i
just
i grabbed it in case you removed it oh
yeah and it has ads no time to cook
kfc how is youtube laughing that brought
to you by
kfc i should just do privacy complaints
for all his videos be like i did not
consent to this i did not consent to
this like this does not have my
permission to put this into the video
like
i'm not like that because i didn't
present so much but
this in particular it's like what the
hell here i'm trying to find okay so
here
so set this up for me okay it was just
like
i was in boston for two weeks with jason
and his family he's like we need to fly
to chicago which is where david's from
and so we did
and we land and this is like an hour two
hours after we land we'd like get in the
hotel room
like i don't know i guess we're just
having like sex or something like that
he's like oh can you go get me a tissue
and i go in there and dave is in the
shower and like we were in the room for
at least an hour from the airport was an
hour like he was there like two hours
in the shower he was just in the
bathroom in the behind the shower
curtain okay
yeah it's yeah it was and they did these
a lot like scare pranks in my house like
david would be in my house or whatever
but we were never like happy
why would that here's the creepy thing
why would jason have sex with you for an
hour knowing david was in the back it
wasn't an hour it was like maybe like 15
minutes okay but i have sex with you
at all that's so disgusting that's what
i said i was just like wait
it's such a violation why did you why
didn't we just like send me in the
bathroom before i got we got naked like
we're naked in this clip
like completely so so here i'm
completely naked in this clip oh you can
tell
here well let's watch other just landed
babe
[Music]
did you see his first podcast where this
girl literally just says oh my god you
didn't get me a car they all just like
bust out laughing and like nothing's
funny it was so
honest i'm not a fan it was number one
trending
how youtube is trending somebody who is
who is like
doing this [ __ ] who's that who's like
literally a predator who's literally
like not respecting anyone's like
like anything it's [ __ ] crazy well
because nobody knows
david's like the king and they don't
know any better nobody's talking about
it i mean
nobody gives a [ __ ] this video is still
monetized on his channel
it does feel like such a lost cause
because like that's why i didn't even
i'm down
i'm i'm okay not talking about it
anymore because it's just such a lost
cause i've been screaming and screaming
well i just want to cover this
because i'm so invested now but after
this i'm gonna move on
yeah i'm saying like it's like it
doesn't even matter so you guys had sex
you went into the bathroom and then
you're like what
did you say anything to them yeah i was
supposed to go back to watching with
jason
and because he he left like that night
like we only came in i think either for
this or something else that was
happening
oh there was like a skunk bit or
something we only came in for 12 hours
and i supposed to go back to boston with
jason
and i literally stayed in illinois by
myself i want to see like hamilton or
something like that and then i flew back
by
myself because i felt so weird about it
and then david never put me in another
vlog for like a month until the tana
thing happened in february where the all
right so he was mad that you got upset
about it yeah i said i was upset about
it
i said like i don't like this that's his
that's his thing
that you can't no when you say i have a
line that you can't cross heath drops
you well here's the yeah exactly and
here's the thing like with this one in
particular because i know everyone's
gonna be like well treasure you're naked
online
at this point i was doing patreon where
i was only posting like new photos gives
a [ __ ] if you're naked online the guy
violated your trust and privacy
jason's ex-wife was like you guys can't
live together because trish was naked
online so i stopped being naked online i
took
all down all my photos and then this
happens i'm like [ __ ] jason's ex-wife is
gonna see this and be like oh they're
naked they're like having sex on camera
or something like that
and that was my concern and i even said
it to jason i said it to david i was
like your ex-wife is like not gonna let
me ever live with you or see the kids
because now i make it again online which
i took down all the naked stuff at that
time
and so that was like my big concern and
i was like it was so
it was all so like much it was just a
lot and i did not go back with jason i
did not go back with david i stayed in
illinois by myself and like
that's great and i love that i love that
his and his apologies to cut you out
yeah because that's that's literally
what it is and it's it's it's uh it's so
insane
so here's another one where that's why i
take a real issue with people like abe
saying that [ __ ] scripted and it's a
show it's [ __ ] not like i
didn't even consent to it i don't even
want to be in it right
it's good to again yeah it's good that
we are putting that forward so people
know
it's not i mean this [ __ ] is real here's
another one where
david tried to set jason up for real to
cheat on you
no he tried to say you uh that's so
humiliating this is
that's just it's just not cool
this one i didn't know like literally
they went to go film something and dave
was like hey can you run to the store
and get like something for like i don't
know another bit like candy or something
and i went
and like it like it this was like a real
issue this was we broke up like
literally
maybe like seven days after this and
stuff like that because this was like a
real issue because like
i don't know what happened i forgot like
it all wasn't in there but he set me up
basically to like
cheat on me it was weird and jason was
like freaking out about it it was it was
he wasn't happy about it either to me he
wasn't happy about admitted to me what
did you do
i didn't do anything i like passed the i
passed it obviously it was really mad
i forgot what i mean we could watch it i
forgot what it was so anyway it's called
trying to catch his girlfriend cheating
now again
this is not a funny thing to do to a
couple especially us because we're so i
was so insecure about it
anyways you know because the tan of
stuff everything was just like a lot for
me it's like
it's like he's trying to break you guys
up it's almost like you're doing it
all right guys here's trisha she's going
in to buy me some chocolate all right
there goes richie she's going in there's
josh how are you doing i'm richie hey
i'm trisha do you think i get your
number no
no no i got a boyfriend you're so sweet
yeah girlfriend like that
oh thank you every good looking girl
this time has a boyfriend yeah
maybe we could just be friends i'm a
nice guy so i always finish last so you
can finish first
i feel like my friend sent me to get
candy he's a vlogger i got candy can
they just be friends
i don't know boyfriend i could be your
man have a hug
you totally passed well one it was like
a young guy which i'm not into i only
like
my men old but um but yeah it was but it
was more it wasn't even that it was just
like
we already were like bumpy me and jason
like rocky with like trust issues and
stuff like that and it was just more of
that thing and i thought
why yeah why do that yeah it was real i
mean that was real i think the guy was
miked up i wasn't
the guy was what the guy was miked up so
people were like oh why is the audio so
clear exactly
like jason so there's that and then
there was one other one which was
actually
in my opinion the most interesting
here's a clip of you confronting david
and jason about
the seth prank and telling them you
weren't comfortable with it it's just
crazy how people found this because
i totally forgot about this clip and
then david's response to you was really
interesting
here watch
when did i yell at you saturday oh i
think we should just break up because
you're gonna react like this
like every time i see anything to bring
up with me sounds like i'm so happy
right now
i'm so happy right now so yeah i have it
working perfectly
she was upset that i was going to make
out with seth and so i flipped out
you're being mad about this well that's
not true i was hearing about the stuff
makeup thing is
crazy it's crazy it's crazy
was that real like him saying it's crazy
three times
no that's the clip unedited you being
mad about your boyfriend making out with
it
oh i can't say that essaying another man
is crazy trisha
crazy crazy crazy
that's like i don't even remember and
then when you did that i was like oh my
god because like yeah
and the thing is is my mo is like
everyone that calls me crazy online or
whatever so it's like that's such an
easy thing to say and like you start
thinking about you're like
even jason just called him when he said
he was gonna do it i was so remember i
was in cleveland when i called him i'm
not comfortable with you doing it this
was a month after dating he's like then
we're gonna break up like if you're not
comfortable with this
then we're breaking up so like i was
like so scared of that excuse me that i
was just like
i don't know this is so redeeming
because i remember you saying i remember
that happening and not being comfortable
with it and here's the footage
and not only you saying you're not
comfortable with it but then david was
i mean look at people misuse gaslighting
all the time this is gaslighting right
because you know something's wrong and
he's trying to convince you that you're
crazy
right i i mean that was everything
though like everything is like treasure
you're crazy you're crazy and i have
like crazy hunties
i feel like you might be this you're the
same one in the room in this case for
sure
i don't care what if he was in a movie
and he had to do that
[Music]
that was always their argument they're
like what if we were an actor if you
were in a movie
right there would be lawyers and
compliance and
producers and all kinds of people that
would tell you you cannot do this
you're not a movie you're a [ __ ]
youtuber you
there's literally no oversight to what
you're doing bro and then they obviously
knew the backlash but they obviously
knew that was except
like upset at the time like it was just
so crazy it's crazy it was like
i don't know that they did that period i
don't know that people find the craziest
[ __ ] like that online but
um i like that tiktok keeps talking
about it i hope more people keep talking
about it it just like
for me i'm just not the voice that's
gonna like help anybody because people
think i'm crazy obsessive all that stuff
like that so like
if you have something that you want to
share you need to share your story and
like at least like i said your series i
know you're like done with it but at
least it was good because it gave like a
sane voice right like somebody who was
like unbiased you know
about it i would just urge people to go
watch that seth interview
yeah yeah that was really good watch the
seth interview and just
listen what the guy is saying because it
is really it's it's just insane it's
just the same the amount of people that
can discredit that
okay it's one thing for me whatever like
trisha's bought her or she brought
broken up with or whatever but it's like
that is just like
he's a friend he tried to help them
after that before that like in and for
people to still discredit him
about everything oh that's not racist
that's not that you shouldn't feel this
way you you know you went along with
jokes like it's
it's so insane to me it's like so it
really
that that's triggering alone i was
watching i was like wow that's crazy and
like
like i said i really only met seth like
a couple of times we never like cross
segged in like videos but
like the fact that you know those
people's stories were so similar it's
like we're not all
it's lying we're not all just making
this up about david and
and for what when people say that it's
like looking for clout like you guys
made a great point
it's like there's no clout to be had
like we just look crazy or obsessive or
whatever people call it there's nothing
like like set what does seth gain it's
like the exact same everyone just calls
just shits on him and he catches [ __ ]
yeah
he has nothing like seth's made a good
point of santa i have nothing to gain in
fact it's humiliating that i have to
come here and share my story
yeah because so many people just don't
take it seriously where if it was he
doesn't want to relive it he said it's
like traumatic
if a girl came forward and said that
about jason like it would be a whole
different thing you know what i mean
like it just
really really sucks that it's like a guy
situation including that guy that came
forward to you in that email and
he said it to me too so it wasn't you
know whatever but it's like it does
happen to guys especially in this
situation where it's very frat boy thing
very like hazing and like people just
like look past it because they're boys i
guess i don't know it's so [ __ ] weird
the one other thing that seth told me
that kind of blew my mind is because
even i when i saw the second prank i was
like oh he's definitely in on it
and he shows a clip of seth saying how
can i cons
he says do i have your consent to try to
make you make out with jason again now
seth said
off-camera he said a bunch of times
don't do this don't do this i'm not
comfortable i don't consent
and then what what david ended up
cutting in
was seth saying how can i consent to
something i don't know
what it is you're gonna do right how
you're gonna do it and he cut that in
and i was like oh my god yeah the
editing is you wanna let's take a break
like a food break oh but you like wanted
to take a minute on this no yes okay
so i've been doing so what we have here
is gay burger
very skinny i thought it was a haircut
but you did say you were starting not
starving you were
good i've been doing like these food
delivery system stuff
i don't want to say the name because i'm
not trying to give anyone a free plug
here
it's nutrisystem payment they should
they yeah yeah pay me
believe it dan no don't believe it
that's good nutrisystem might give us
the plug to be the next marie osmond
yeah they were like why don't anyway so
these guys
they send you the food and you eat it
because i'm just so desperate to lose
but i'm just so tired of being fat i
just hate being fat it's just the worst
thing so
i said i'm doing nutrisystem so they
send me the food
and these people got me on
with peace and love i hate to say it but
it's like
the anne frank diet can i say that
i'm not sure the what happened she got
starved in the concentration camps or
something
she was in the attic for a long time
maybe she ate
well though there like the flowers in
the attic they ate mice i think
well because they were somewhat where we
could talk we're probably talking too
much about anne frank but
but she was living a kind family was
hiding her family in the attic
and so they may have been feeding them
well so maybe it's not a good analogy
probably not that well though she looks
skinny
like on the book cover yeah she was a
little girl
oh really yeah how long was she in the
attic for then a few years so she aged
into an adult at some point
no she died young oh she died in the
attic
well she was taken from that by who
nazis
yeah um so we are we're just talking
about the left was her memoir
at mcdonald's today we just saw a name
that was half jewish half german and i'm
like i wonder if they
conceived in the holocaust what was it
wine truck oh we
shouldn't say it the name was a half
jewish half german
name and i was yiddish why are you
letting her come to these crazy
conclusions
moses but in the holocaust maybe they
had the baby that's where it came like
well there was a lot of german jews
before the holocaust
a lot of them well that's what i'm just
trying a lot of them and there ain't
anymore
you get what i'm saying no because he's
still alive this guy we saw this guy's
name on
a billboard so he survived okay he
survived
good for him i'm faster anyway
so i'm on the diet i'm so fascinated by
it for real
well there's plenty there's plenty of
reading material trust me
it's very well documented anyway
so i'm on that diet there i'm on a
thousand calories a day i'm
so sad and miserable it's sad it's
miserable it's not it's not okay
they should not put people through this
they go you're gonna eat a thousand
calories a day i'm like dude what are
you talking about like this is this is
not healthy to do it but i'm doing it
you're so tall you're like 510 like
you're right or five how tall you don't
know
11. are you three yep i'm so bad with
people's heights i really don't know i'm
like really bad at measurement but so
but anyway ela is the one that suggested
this so i mean peace of mind
i swear to god she's the one to stand
please for the record it was ela yeah
thank you
it was i think you used your enemies as
your excuse well of course i do i'm on a
thousand calories a day
i hate that i'm this person can i tell
you every single friendship relationship
friend group i've been in
i'm always the person like let's go be
with trisha we can just pick out and eat
it's like
that's not what i do all the time i'm
just no it's not to eat with
noah i'm i have self-control i i
skip dinners a lot i eat salads like i'm
not just this person to be like let's
just be a fat fake today with trish
it's trish day it's time to eat like a
big fat pig everything
i'm just kidding well these are
interesting i don't like the way these
are label oh he labeled them
so this is from a place that caught my
eye it's called gay burger you just want
to be controversial
no it's not my burger when she said that
i was like oh
cancelled i it's not my food
all the proceeds go to supporting ian
why don't you where did what are they
doing
ian uh all the proceeds go to the los
angeles
lgbt center for homeless youth isn't
that great
yeah and it was started by elijah daniel
which is so crazy good for him like he's
kind of been like a problematic youtuber
in the past and i was like where did he
go and
he was like a rapper and now he's like
doing philanthropy this is cool
i like it mm-hmm so the gay burger
is like the only real food i've had that
looks really bad actually i'm not gonna
what were these
called or the fries called uh they're
called the uh
the big jizz very gay fries these are
very
gay fries these are gays as it gets
these are gay fries these are very good
what are we going to do for gay pride
month
this is it okay this is my gay pride
year right here
so we want to name some of these
sandwiches off that we have
uh yeah the uh the one i think you're
eating is the beef me up scotty
this is beef me up scotty i might hit
this
i'm just going to give this a real
review because this is our milk thing
two patties what's mine called mine's
called the no more milk daddy
oh this is vegan not that daddy is so
good no more milk
daddy no more milk daddy you literally
don't like i don't like daddy anymore i
think cause i'm old
i'm like a mommy now so oh it says like
pickles oh
go ahead keep bringing them yum uh then
the other one's the love me daddy
love me daddy what's with the daddy i
think elijah daniel is also old huh
you say daddy like unintentionally you
do the daddy
daddy like zaddy daddy daddy um
yeah i don't know i just have daddy
issues they're resolved oh they are
yeah how do you resolve daddy issues
time just time yeah i think you just
because you talk with them
did you work it out with them no my
dad's like not a talker we're cool we're
really good but just like you just let
things go
yeah i think over time you just gotta
like that's great except him not being
around for
most of your life and they're like you
know he's here now so yeah
to heirs to human it's air that means
to air is to human well i said it to air
is human
human's hair oh you don't like the gay
the gay chicken what is this one called
i like chicks oh well no wonder it's not
good it's gay burger
oh you think it's perfectly bad yeah
they're like i like chick the straight
the straight burger oh yeah like chicks
ew
is that really it's called i like chicks
yeah
so what are they called the straight
burger why wasn't i like dicks or
something
i like chicks with oh oh dicks for
lesbians
or pansexuals or bisexuals okay so look
at me i'm so
see get cancelled we're done not me i'm
done
um and then is there any other [ __ ] come
give me can we get back
love me and daddy you say daddy's so
funny
how say daddy three times daddy
daddy daddy daddy
you know you're saying it funny how
should i say it say it i'll try and
repeat how you're saying it
daddy yeah that's how you say it yeah
daddy
well yeah that's a weird kink you have
or something because you're making me
say it so many times
you're like hit three times you're
literally walking around going daddy
that is the name of it i know but it's
the way you say it
ian is there any other funny names uh
there is the uh
baby daddy grilled cheese baby daddy
what is that oh the the dad where's that
i didn't see that
i found it over one here oh you
whoa you're holding out on the baby
daddy
no here have it no have it no i like the
name i love the name no no there's a
vegan one right there
do you want the grilled cheese or you
want the the grilled chicken i'll do it
later
daddy daddy the microphone
what was this one called baby daddy
the baby daddy grilled cheese baby daddy
grilled cheese
what else we got oh wait how is this
vegan oh and it's also just like
shallots
you know what it looks like as a diaper
change like so hard changed my diaper
daddy
like not even being funny
[Music]
that's insane there's no way that's a
sandwich
daddy change my diaper this is what a
dirty diaper looks like
have you ever changed a diaper dude i've
changed a billion diapers
why do you think i haven't changed a
diaper
oh i don't know about this place i mean
this burger's good but it could just be
because i've literally been living in
you're starving i'm like north korean
diet is that more acceptable
north korea diet i eat my neighbors dogs
they have youtube over there so they
can't get offended
yeah but we all don't like north korea
so it's not good
was it north korea or south korea north
for sure
wait really oh
yeah cause all the 90-day fiance people
are usually from north korea
no oh south korea yeah oh north koreans
are not allowed on
90 day fiance
interesting well i'll try the wait
what's love me daddy is that the burger
oh yeah yeah oh i'm just like not into
like sauces and
this one's a burger wait wasn't there
another beef burger vegan but what i
don't understand what's vegan like the
patty looks crazy on this one
yeah i think it's a vegan patty
such a dainty little bite
no good we're out on gay burger that
tastes like an intestine
that is so gross look at that it looks
like little poops i can't
i want to try it oh oh it's so hard i
know
oh it's like a rock part this one's good
i don't know what happened to this one
they are um
i like the idea i like that it goes for
something profitable you guys don't eat
that it's for sure
my dog didn't die oh my god don't say
that
well i don't even know what it is it's
like weird ass
yeah that was weird that wasn't even
like plant-based like the impossible
whopper is pretty good but that is not
it
it's not plant-based what do you think
it's made of
rat is rap poop uh vegan no
i don't think so so anyway that was gay
burger
next time let me pick something i could
have brought some shamrock shakes up in
this i thought it was fun
funny interesting charity i thought
elijah daniel did that that was pretty
good
because him and christine saw duck you
remember her remember you don't remember
christine said elco
she what she became like this
like political actor actually has to be
friends you guys are very politically
politically charged is that the word
do you think elijah daniels would be
happy about our review of his food
yeah i think like all publicity is good
publicity
even if we're like your burger tastes
like dog [ __ ] he didn't make it he
probably didn't even try it
oh he's doing the sound for you to go
back the [ __ ] off the mic
um yeah it was dope
how was your uh valentine's i was just
gonna ask you that i mean mine was all
over tic tac i didn't see yours
we didn't do anything we did nothing
we're being parents it's like
okay but he goes to bed early at six not
lately
so what'd you guys do you didn't order
special food a little pizza
oh no yeah yeah on valentine's day
look eli doesn't care about food trust
me if i was dating someone who had
with peace and love someone who cared
about don't say it
with me some love just don't say it
about food the same way i do you know
what i mean but ela's like
i think we care about food differently i
enjoy my food i love it i think you kind
of just like
shovel it back i don't think you like it
i don't think you enjoy it they're in
food shame me
i'm not food chipping you i don't think
you enjoy it like i enjoyed it i'm an
animal i think no
i think you're feeding like an
insecurity mine is more like a luxury
that i'm indulging in
i think i'm over indulging i think
you're feeding an insecurity
i think there's two separate things okay
whatever makes you feel better
because you're not you don't me and you
are the same
you think fat yes
exactly i love having a fat friend i've
never really had like a fat friend so we
can both just like laugh at
ourselves we could be like we should
just say [ __ ] become like the 600
pound sisters why don't we go the
opposite way and be like hey we're gonna
be this like fit couple that got a
makeover not a couple but you know what
i mean
can we do acrobatic like
acrobatic like ribbon stuff like in the
um ribbon stuff
yeah like in the circus daddy's wearing
ribbons
yeah like you know in um greatest
showman zendaya when her and zac efron
are flying through the air on ribbons i
feel like we would do that so good i was
listening to it this morning like we can
just be like rewrite the stars and like
tumble down out of the aerial gymnastics
i have no idea what you're talking about
you don't know what acrobatic gymnastics
are is it just this [ __ ] with the ribbon
the ribbons are hanging from the ceiling
and you're spinning down the ribbons off
the ceiling
do you think those ribbons could support
us yes
zachary and zandaya did it they did a
beautiful dance yeah they probably weigh
like 100 pounds zac efron's tiny he was
like 110 pounds that guy runs pure
muscle so he probably weighs like your
weight he's like he's five two
that's not true look up zac efron's eye
he's like five six probably
one time they approached me to work out
with zac efron for his youtube channel
oh he wanted to he wanted to zach
everyone's five
eight five eight tiny manlet
that's not bad yeah i mean that's like
normal well the thing is like can we do
acrobatics
at least i'm taller than zac efron like
cool
give me that are you i feel like you're
not that tall
acrobatic stunts what did dr phil
invite you on the show for him i was
actually curious about that oh well i
meant to say this last time and then our
show got hijacked by um
more important things which is david um
no we were like away for the weekend i
was like a week and a half ago
and i've been on the drill show before
so anyways dr phil people email me like
hey
i should just say exactly okay let me
tell you how they phrased this email
because normally
i if it's a talk show i'm like no thank
you i'm not interested because it's
usually
trying to make you look bad all those
shows are exploitative whatever and i've
already done the dr phil so anyways i
get an email
okay this is how it's worded and then
i'll tell you what the phone call was
she said
good afternoon i'm writing to you on
behalf of a producer on the dr phil show
we are interested in discussing
your youtube journey and your life story
for an upcoming show that tapes in los
angeles california this month
if appearing on the show and talking
about your experience is something that
you're open to please reply so reiterate
we are interested in discussing your
youtube journey and life story for an
upcoming show and i was like
dope okay they're gonna do like a
profile on me so then i get the phone
call and it's this guy and it was on
speakerphone so
my fiance can attest to this that this
is real i'm not lying because everyone
thinks i lie about everything
and he's like oh trish like such a fan
blah blah
blah cool and then he's just like yeah
he goes so we love that you're like
outspoken and that you know you're
always in drama he goes but we don't
want the drama on the show he goes but
is it ever has it ever interfered with
your family life like has family ever
like
you know they don't like like approve
what you're doing and they would want to
come on the show and confront you and i
was like no my family's totally fine
they like are totally proud of me they
love what i'm doing whatever blah blah
blah
and he's like okay well what about if
there's like a problem in like your
relationship maybe like your fiance
doesn't approve
whatever so it became like this
exploited a thing and i was like dude
what like i'm pretty sad i'm pretty
happy in life or whatever now
and he's like yeah i saw you just got a
house and you're engaging well and i was
just like
i hate when they like waste my time but
basically when we come on the show and
just make up a fake like
yeah right like you with a nice email
yeah that they want but they wanted me
to be like but don't lie about what the
show is just be like oh we want to
exploit like if your family has a
problem with you and i
[ __ ] hate that wasting my time so
much because we were like on vacation
and i put aside like an hour to talk to
these people and i was like waiting
waiting waiting for this phone call
and that's what the phone call was i'm
like dr phil's fake as [ __ ] you know who
you know who just had dr phil on their
youtube channel jason
phil went on jason what does that say
about the company you keep dr phil was
on
literal a literal harasser predator
channel no it is
two guys have attested to this now dr
phil's got to do his homework
well dr phil's a piece of [ __ ] he's a
croc his face he's got like
he looks like mr potato head he's fake
dr phil speak i want to see that
oh yeah is it updated dr phil yeah what
doctorate are you in psychology
exactly he's literally like he looks
like mr potato
i [ __ ] anything and i would never [ __ ]
dr phil can somebody please acknowledge
how much
dr phil looks like mr potato head what's
mr potato head
dude his face is so weird it looks like
it looks like somebody put his like
eyebrows
his nose and then like no the nose goes
here you guys don't know what i'm
talking here mister
thank you moses knows what i'm talking
about here
mr potato head is exactly dr phil
[Laughter]
except like but i wouldn't even go as
far to say mr potajeto head
is maybe better looking than dr phil
less wrinkles
his his features are symmetrical at
least
dr phil you want to talk about looking
like a corpse
that's what i'm saying like in person
i'm not even being funny
because i worked he wears a lot of
makeup i can tell you no but he
literally looked like one of those
corpses i was a makeup assistant
and he looked like a cadaver or they
that oh he looks like open casket
funeral
didn't i say that about you yeah that's
what i'm saying that was my transition
because that's a real one
and he was so dead behind the eyes and i
was like did they just put like a
heartbeat into him it's like young
frankenstein where they just put a brain
into somebody that was already dead and
i'm just like what is this
he's too good of a money maker he
probably died five years ago and they
just revived him
like a weekend at bernie's you know they
say that symmetry is like the key to
beauty
and if you look long at mr potato head
you'll notice that he has perfect
symmetry
and what i'm trying to say is i think i
want to [ __ ] mr potato head his eyes are
too close
right they said if you have a
firefighter eyes it's like more
beautiful
you're more fly if you have far far
apart far apart not that far apart
mine are perfect how far apart you
trying to spread your eyes
i don't know i got some white said eyes
i think it's a syndrome i forget what
it's called oh people think i have foz
that i'm a flaws baby because your eyes
are far apart yeah it's like if you look
at
your eyes aren't there so there's
nothing wrong with being a foss baby
first of all
second of all why do you call it a pause
baby that seems derogatory
oh i don't know that's what people call
me maybe what is a foss baby fetal
alcohol syndrome
oh have you looked at their theirs their
their characteristics are me
like the diagram of a baby with fetal
alcohol syndrome not there's nothing
wrong again nothing wrong with it if
you're functioning ian will you read the
the
features of it let me show you because
it's like it like the diaphragm the
diagram is your mom drink alcohol
i don't know you should ask her if
you're a boss baby
that could be she probably deny it okay
so these kind of do and again there is
nothing wrong with this where i'm just
saying like this could be me
flat midface me then upper lip
me short nose me that kid looks totally
normal i'm confused by this
um small eye openings flat this looks
like a normal girl i mean what what are
they on
about i don't understand these could
these people look normal you have to
send that to damn
okay i want to ask you about something
what i'm nervous
i hate when you don't prep me because i
gave you the doll olstein like a bit
you're like here send this to me like no
you're gonna prep to like make a case
against this
because i want to know a poor girl she's
part of a criminal energy no she
actually said i respect ethan's opinion
to like not like my uncle but also like
hear some facts
yeah he pays her okay
i want to ask you about a video i saw on
your channel okay trisha
and this is something i've harped on you
foreign it's a great old
do you know what i'm going to say moses
well i'm surprised
yeah both of you guys this is something
i've told you time and time again
trisha hire a [ __ ] editor
oh what did i do okay
i know this is yeah yeah you uploaded a
mooc called a video called mukbang in my
new house with moses
the first like two minutes
not two minutes is literally you guys
anyone walking just candidly standing in
your
kitchen why what is this well i was
doing a tic tac here so i'm like oh guys
look at this
but why is this in your video oh i but
it ended up roughly too i didn't i
forgot to edit it
so you don't even edit your videos i
usually splice them together like i put
clips together there was two more clips
that i forgot to put with this video
i think it's amazing that you can upload
a video on your youtube channel
with two minutes of dead air
and nobody even said anything about it
they're like a lot of people said
something about it i uploaded really
i went through the comments and everyone
there everyone everyone's like this is
trisha's channel
no everyone's like why did it end so
abruptly like everyone did say that
because this one did end very abruptly
this is like if we started the podcast
we just stood here and stared at the
camera
there's something real about it i like
it don't act like it was intentional
well no this was definitely not
intentional
uh we were i was in such a grumpy mood
to him this was the day we moved and i
was so
you guys almost had an ace family moment
oh that would have been bad yeah
you guys start fighting or something a
little bit you squabble a little bit i
we
i tried to leave it like i don't think
we did anything bad in this because i
was a little like
you never know
no one watched this all candid wait why
are you
so boring we have other food coming this
is like
oh you're on camera now you're talking
about yeah okay i couldn't tell you're
on
your content is so riveting i couldn't
even tell thank you
i feel like we're friends now i don't
even like making fun of you anymore like
that
um yeah we we talked on the okay we
talked on the phone for the first time
on friday night and it gave me so much
anxiety before and after
oh you didn't like it i hated it it was
awful and one
moses was sleeping so i was like really
anxious i like stayed up all night i was
like in a corner
literally like shaking because i was
thinking like did i [ __ ] it up did i say
something's wrong like i hate being on
the phone with somebody
oh you were in your head over what we
talked about yeah
oh i was like [ __ ] i [ __ ] it up like i
didn't say the right thing like i hate
people i won't call you anymore no i
liked it was nice
oh but you like this yeah cause i was
like oh that was cool because you're
like we're like friends
and then i got really i couldn't breathe
when you said that i was like like i
literally
well i called her i was like look at us
trisha we're on the phone we're friends
isn't this funny and i couldn't breathe
so i just started going off on a tanning
about something else i was like
so anyways yeah i started talking really
fast i was like okay so then we're going
to i just trying to like
go to the subject so we don't have to
make small talk like this glaze past
this
i thought it was a great conversation
and then i got off and i was uh
i was happy about it i was happy about
it the next morning i was like oh yeah i
got to talk to ethan
last night like we just had a
conversation okay
it was cool i liked it it was fun and
was also sleeping so i was like oh you
missed that we were like all on the
phone together
like right it's a good time um we were
talking about the drama and i was just
you know wanted to talk to her because
it was all so intense
how about marilyn manson i haven't made
another story
okay who could have ever seen that one
coming
marilyn manson the totally normal
looking dude ended up being a total
pervy
marilyn manson when we went to obsidi
signing a hot topic out with my sister
you know the hot topic signing yeah
that's like the uncle's thing
this is like 2006. this is a while ago
like when he was with dwants i think how
did he ever recover from that
i don't know but he wrote on our album
kelly she watches if you have the album
covers let me know because we had him
sign her album covers and he said to me
he goes you have really big tits and i
was like oh okay thank you
what wait wait this is not the worst
part i was 18. my sister was like 13 and
he goes to my sister
oh no he's okay sorry we got this
background
you know he always had this persona like
deep down underneath the makeup i'm just
a normal
totally cool dude no he he went to my
sit my sister was first i had my sister
go first she was 13
and he goes you have really big tits and
he wrote that on her cd cover
and then he said to me he goes he wrote
he said to me he goes ugh i like yours
yours are even bigger tits
that was my story man that's creepy
right off the bat is someone who doesn't
even know
yeah it's kind of weird this is music
sexual i've never listened to it like
later on his music did like heart-shaped
glasses that was one with every
every evan rachel won some of his exits
said horrible things about him
um yeah that's my only story i have with
him you never hear that about adam
sandler you never hear like
no could you imagine if there was like a
string of like people
oh i couldn't do it tiger woods it was
kind of like that well tiger's like a
alpha athlete adam sandler is like
alpha billionaire yeah but he doesn't
have that like uh
that those athletes are all like jacked
up on testosterone like
steroids and [ __ ] lamar odom versus
aaron carter
you mentioned that and i was like i
don't know about that i used to date
aaron carter we went on a couple dates
he's been in some vlogs he was
never gonna say anything but him
fighting
no
average average because he's pretty tall
right uh
no yeah skinny he's very skinny like 100
pounds but
not skinny shaving i love skinny i think
it's hot and you look fat
uh yeah is that what i can get
so let me see if there's any okay hold
on let's see if we don't do anything
else
okay psa if you see me out in public you
know what is the most annoying thing
and like i love that people like know me
and like one talk to me and take
pictures with me that's my favorite
thing the whole world like i truly truly
love having conversations with people
out in public
like i love it like it's so cool people
like still care about who i am
[Music]
two very annoying things no like it
literally pissed me off so much is like
okay a lot of things one is so if you
have your friend come up to me like i
have no idea who you are but that person
like my friend wants a picture with you
like no i'm not gonna do it like you're
[ __ ] annoying
two i have no idea who you are but can
you do it can i do a tick tock with you
well [ __ ] you you know who i am and two
no i'm not gonna do a ticket
three asking me to do more than one tick
tock with you in the middle of sirloin
table we're like trying to buy pots and
pans and literally this like 14 year old
they don't want a picture they don't
want to talk to you they want to do a
[ __ ] tick tock with you
and then they ask you to do like
multiple ones in target this girl comes
up to me
a dozen times can you say hi to this
person okay come back can you she keeps
following me around target to say hi to
people
and do a [ __ ] tic tac the tick tock
is crazy because
you know they're going to get a shitload
of views with you being in it
just i have like a family that's private
that doesn't like to be on camera they
don't like you know like
i finally did we were in that sirlot
table which is like this like boring
kitchen
thing and i finally was like no because
this guy could just like it's hard to
say no it feels
so hard this 14 year old boy was like oh
you are but my friend wants to tick-tock
with you i said i literally don't have
time to do this i'm like i can take a
picture and say hi
just say i don't do that but uh i can
say hi no but you know what they're all
filming you at all times like
they come up to you filming you so you
just look like an [ __ ] no matter what
and i'm just like i'll take a picture
with you like whatever it's just
and it's like not again i don't complain
because i like love taking pictures i
love talking no but these
yeah i get that that's the least
favorite thing people say to me on the
street is like
um i or first of all this is the
weirdest thing and sometimes
you'll get like mobbed and then someone
they're like i don't know who you are
but can you take a photo with me
i was like why do you want a [ __ ]
photo you lit
i'm just usually like hey hey okay when
that happens because i just want to get
on with it
don't come near me now no no i don't oh
i haven't i don't go outside with the
covid that would be i'd be like nah dude
yeah we
like couldn't that happened we didn't
get mobbed up in that back
is what i i don't go in public nobody
recognized they left they opened up the
restaurant for us to eat indoor because
the outdoors causing too much chaos of
us eating outside because like all of us
oh for real yeah you're such a big deal
oh my god for some reason
where were you guys eating it was in san
luis obispo so it was like a smaller
town
wait you guys were went out
oh my god this person in the car ran red
lights to chase says mo i mean what's
this
you guys got to eat inside an exclusive
indoor season yeah we got to eat that
dolly party well i'm going to report you
to the uh
cdc sorry about that that's a violation
there we were the only ones in there
yeah but rules are rules
that's crazy people were like trying to
hug me and i'm like ah call me
what the [ __ ] i was actually freaked out
we got tested like twice after that
because
i freaked out more for you guys because
my like like someone in my family's
already had coconuts like i'm not as
worried about it
yeah did we not talk about it i feel
like well people are like why don't you
talk about my mom talked about her so
she can talk about it she had it right
before christmas like right when we went
on a break
my mom when we got engaged no so
like right the day after no the day we
got engaged the night my brother's like
calling me and we were like up in the
sand dunes or whatever
so we weren't getting reception we come
down and i'm like so excited we got
engaged and my brother
was like kept calling me and he like
never called me it's really rare for my
brother to call me not that we're not
close she just has a family whatever
he'll come he's like mom's really really
sick and this is like the 19th so this
is when we're on break now
this is the 19th and i was like oh [ __ ]
and so we were four hours away like do
you want to come home mom's like i'm
fine
two days later she tests she tests
positive for coped oh i was always
negative my sister
didn't know this yeah well i knew you're
like weird about us i didn't want to say
anything but at the same time like this
was during our break and we got tested
like you know what i mean like
i just don't want you to like freak out
because i get it you know whatever
um and but this was our two week break
and honestly like i said
if like we got tested so much and if it
was like not our two week break
well anyway i want to know how your mom
how your mom i cancelled multiple glams
that week like that that following
monday i was supposed to get glammed i
canceled it because like
because i'll tell you why so yeah my mom
she was living in an apartment building
at the time we just got our house now
but like she was living in an apartment
building so we think she must have got
it from there because like i get tested
all the time and we never leave like we
go once in a while and my sister
literally never never leaves so we're
like this is so weird that she got it we
got tested whatever she got it
and my mom has pre-existing conditions
so we were like a little nervous but she
was like i'm fine i'm fine everything's
like okay and i was like okay
but then what was it christmas eve
christmas eve she calls
911 she calls an ambulance and my mom
never complains my mom's on a hype
contract like excuse me she doesn't
complain about anything and so
she's like i like i literally she's like
crying she called me and she's like
like i don't know if anyone got
disconnected can you call them so i'm
calling 911
to send her to my mom's house and my mom
basically 91 took her
vitals and everything like that and
they're really bad like she's doing
really really bad and they're like
we have to leave you here like we can't
take it oh my god
this is christmas eve and my mom is like
calling my brother and she's like crying
she's
like i know i'm gonna die like i'm not
ready to die like it was like really
traumatic my mom is just not that person
so
this is christmas eve and that's what
was the symptom she was having trouble
breathing
yeah she already has like a condition
with like she's like on medication for
and stuff like that for like her
breathing like
lungs related and so she yeah she oh she
got she couldn't breathe she literally
was like i'm
i'm gonna die and like she and she's had
covenant she had covered at that point
for like
a week and again this is the 19th this
is when we're on our break like
everything's done like every
whatever and i had just tested for my
music videos like everything
i'm still negative i've been negative
thank god um i think i think i hadn't
covered like a while ago in my opinion i
haven't gotten tested for it but i think
i had it like a really long time ago
but um so anyways my my brother was like
hey can you drive mom so i i had to take
my mom down to irvine because
my mom's like there's just no way i'm
gonna like make it like i'm literally
going to die and i was just like [ __ ] so
you drove with her in the car scary yeah
so but like what am there was nothing
else i can do in my mom and i know
hospitals do have like they can give you
something like there is something if you
ask for i forget what it's called
there's something with like an r or
something that they can help you
yeah yeah yeah yeah so yeah i don't care
how much it is like when you get my mom
well she might need a ventilator if
she's really treatment
yeah so because of her age like they
were actually really good like we were
surprised
they had a tent and stuff like that yeah
so i'm driving i put my mom in my back
seat windows are down i have like three
masks i'm like really scared i mean
um so we drove her down and whatever and
i guess i don't know what they i guess
they ended up doing something she didn't
get better right away but she did get
better and
that's so scary i didn't know anything
about that yeah well i know you knew
someone else i had covered i know you
guys and i rightfully so but like i said
if we didn't come back to filming till
like the 6th of january so it's like
she had already touched a negative a
bunch of times like we didn't see her at
all like for christmas we didn't see her
we didn't see my sister
we were supposed to see my sister on
christmas didn't see her i'm not mad you
didn't tell me it sounds like you're
responsible just worried that you went i
mean
i can't believe you went through all
that and i didn't even know yeah it was
like a lot
it was it was really really scary that's
why i get so pissed i like get so pissed
at people because she has an apartment
building where there's like a lot of
young kids like she's like
or she was in a beach city and like
nobody wear matt it's hermosa nobody
wears masks on hermosa beach that's
where she lived and whatever and it just
like pisses me off so much because like
and we know we know two people who died
like personal family members that have
died yeah i know a few people that have
died now it's like
everybody's got to know a few people
that died now and the fact like
okay i was watching the joe rogan
podcast and i saw a clip of it and joe
rogan goes and someone goes are you
getting the vaccine
and joe gordon was like no i don't need
it
and it pissed me off so much and then i
saw elon musk
someone say are you getting a vaccine
and elon goes no
like defensive like of course not i
don't need it
like why so arrogant about it like if
you're gonna be a dumbass just stay
silent about it like don't encourage
other people to be dumb asses like just
passing it around
it's it is it's so upsetting does my
hair look good i just got a haircut it
feels kind of like
round here yeah i feel like when you get
fresh haircuts it has to grow out a
couple days right
yeah i think you should like bleach your
hair or something no blonde
no no how about for a photo shoot
okay okay i have a really good idea
for a look it'd be fun if we were doing
like dress up i'd bleach it
i think you should bleach blonde your
hair god i look like such a freak
you did i'd rather shave off my eyebrows
and head
oh yeah for for a video yeah yeah how
come i wanted to ask you what's the deal
with your black hands
you do black hand it's racist for sure
no okay show the back you did the video
about av when you're all angry and your
hands were all black and i was like girl
what's that away from the point you were
the one that's like oh distracted you're
like look at her hands that's not the
point of the video
okay but why are your hands black like
how how does that happen
my spray tan lady oh somebody did that
to you
yeah i would figure that with just like
a sloppy soap no when i do it myself
yeah and then i paid her god i love her
she's really sweet
but then on top of it she wanted a tic
toc shout out i'm like girl my hands
look crazy
like shout out to my girl if you want to
look like me
they were worse like wait how did she
[ __ ] up your hands like that what's i
don't understand how that happens
well she just i think you're supposed to
put lotion on them or something like
that just the hands more absorbent or
something
i've never had that i don't know like
why would you even do the hands just
skip the hands
no you definitely need hands but it just
like it looks kind of crazy it's just
like absorbed really crazy that's
awesome i saw it and i was like dude
what
it looked like you had a tanning
accident where you were like
wow i can't believe how much you pay her
i paid her a lot because she has to come
out to like where we live we're further
from l.a now so i
like paid her how much i think two
hundred dollars which is a lot for a
spray tan and wanting a shout out to i'm
like okay like you gotta pick one
it's like a tick girl shout out that's
my biggest platform i'm kind of popping
on there
i had to do a prank today for a
sponsorship on tik tok oh you got a
sponsor on tick tock yeah
through the tick tock platform yeah how
does that work i gotta get on i i show
you
but um yeah through the marketplace and
so they they paid me money to do this
like dare it was like the drink
it's called like do a drink it's not a
sponsorship now but like there's like a
do or drink and see if they wanted me to
do a dare and they picked the dare that
i have to do like it was on a card and
it was to call it pizza place
and ask for a penis-shaped pizza and i
hate doing that so much like i had the
most anxiety this morning doing it i was
like oh my god for like an app or
something
no it's a card game you pull a card and
you have to do what it says or you have
to take a shot harass poor
retail workers she was pissed i think
she was annoyed about it she's like yeah
no
it's like listen i got [ __ ] look i make
minimum wage why are you [ __ ] with me
i hope they said it was okay did you say
penis shaped yeah
that's rude to the worker
yeah it was how did you get paid for
that um
i don't know what should i say i don't
know not as much as you would think
i don't know it's weird i'm so curious
it's so weird
it was good for like a 60 second
tick-tock you know what i mean like it's
pretty good but yeah i want to i'll do
i'll
ask for a penis you [ __ ] i know you
would you love me i'll take a pee i'll
take 10 penis pies please
pay me bye i can't wait for tick-tockers
to just go away like tick-tockers like
not tick-tock but tick-tockers
i'm so over all of them did you see the
do you care about any of this
okay no bryce hall he's the little guy
with the little hands and the
one who wears the the little guy he's
also really short
why i never heard that about him bryce
hall height dan's on it he knows
what is the feed on people's height it's
all i have oh he's sick that's not him
i'm 5 11. i'm not even that tall but
like
he's not even like the bryce hall he's
like bryce hall the [ __ ]
great tick tock tick tock i know loser
try to get the real brace all name
then talk to me for real though okay
well not that crazy but um manlet
oh yeah it's so normal and it's also so
embarrassing because he thinks like
ariana grande is using him for clout but
meanwhile he's not the first bryce hall
to pop up when you google him
did you hear him say that's so good yeah
because ariana grande is like i wish
people would stop going to saddle ranch
during a pandemic and he goes wow ariana
grande just trying to use us for clout
okay we see you it's like really like
and they're not this yeah look it up
bryce saw ariana grande
so what did bryce hall do um
um okay so he did oh yeah it comes up to
it
so he did like a prank over the weekend
that he was cheating on his girlfriend
wait are you seeing it
i think i saw the photo where everyone's
like this is obviously fake
it was like a valentine's day thing yeah
but here's the worst part
is
the media bro you're not you're not a
big deal
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i'm pranking
the media
yeah my phone is just full of fetal
alcohol babies thank you trisha if you
guys are curious
it just looks like a normal kid was he
got a big forehead yeah i have that too
okay let me see let me see look at me
okay oh look at you
does your mom oh you don't have like
these really thin lips i did these are
all injections
remember the bruised lip situation that
was from injecting my lips so does your
mom drink alcohol
um she did yeah oh you're an alcohol
baby
yeah maybe but doesn't affect like your
mental acuity too
but you're pretty sharp i think you're
not when it comes to
everything i was going to pay 80 000.
what you do this weekend right
well you also don't know what gravity is
so there's that
um right right wait
what what's up you said you didn't know
what happened
you've known each other for a while
addison approved of this girl
okay my god said lauren we've known each
other for a while addison approved of
this girl i'm gonna be pranking the
media
into thinking that i'm a cheating
scumbag so i'm going to facetime lauren
right now right and ask her if she's
down
this is the generation raised by david
jobrick that thinks this is like so
funny
i'm going to prank people to thinking
i'm a scumbag it's like hey
it's not a prank to [ __ ] with the media
maybe a cheating prank dude i haven't
been in a scandal in a while so i feel
like it's just that time you know
all right so now we need a paparazzi
that we can trust to make this
completely believable do you trust me
because i think he's cute i mean like
kevin me and addison are about to be
like
no but it's like 12 year olds it's like
you always know like heartthrobs are
always for like the young girls it's not
the people their age like 18 year old
girls are not finding bryce hall
attractive like it's like the little
kids you know what's interesting
when i was a kid jonathan taylor thomas
was like the heartthrob do you know
that and i look back at pictures and
hear them pull it up and i
john he looked a little bit like an elf
right but i love elves like bernard the
l from the santa claus is like one of my
favorite elves
do you want to [ __ ] house um
no i mean and he's pretty handsome
but like it was the hair parting and
everything it's just so funny like
where's he
look at this hair it's like a
straight-up [ __ ] whole body mullet he
kind of looks like rosie o'donnell
yeah little huddy don't you bring that
back
don't do it oh my god oh the hell
that's a lot he looks like little honey
like that's an attractive
boy i mean that's a lot though that
whole outfit and everything
i don't know why he's oh that's a tom
sawyer didn't he play huckleberry finn
or something
or tom sawyer i don't remember but but
you want to see what he looks like now
it's kind of interesting to see just
yeah they never age well macaulay falcon
is better though
he looks better now than he did didn't
you say i don't know
what did he offer you to do on his
podcast no oh here's what he's like
hawkins podcast oh wow he looks like
tyler
he looks like a lesbian jonathan taylor
thomas became tyler oakley
is it racist is it mean to is it bad to
say he looks like a lesbian
i can't say he looks like a lesbian i
think like that's maybe now in 2021 i
think there is that stereotypical
lesbian haircut that's
offensive but yeah he looks like a
lesbian that just means like you look
like ellen
because there's a lot of guys that like
look like alan and i think it's funny to
say you look like a lesbian no good
moses i mean
look look as someone who's trying to go
from there's got to be some line i could
[ __ ] around with
maybe not gay rights lying i'm not
saying take the rights away i'm just
saying he looks like a lesbian i think
that's like stereotyping
i'm not listen everybody knows what i
mean though
i just gotta do a quick shout out to him
and then we'll be done oh but also back
to back
is this really the time i mean talk
about hate joel osteen is not pro gay
rights he's pro-jewish rights he let
them in what does that have to do with
gays
they're the same they're both oppressed
yeah but what if what if he
likes the jews and hates the gays joel
osteen hates the gays
that's so not true oh please i guarantee
that's how they make the money
say that you can't just say that
right somebody fact check that how does
your awesome feel about gay people keeps
wanting to work with me they keep trying
to come back with more offers
they couldn't cut me in huh are they
making are they making it a better
offer like a more lucrative first and i
was like no i'm passing worse
and then they're like how about let's
try one test and i was like maybe but
then they haven't gone back to me
i'm trying to find the thing anyways
back to bryce hall before we finish that
whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa you
can't transition from saying pro gay
rights oh de bryce hall
i can't say jonathan taylor thomas looks
like a lesbian
and then say i want to give a shout out
to joel osteen who literally hates gay
people
oh here it is joel osteen tells larry
king scripture says homosexuality is a
sin
i rest my case phil
well we need to cancel the old scene on
this planet hello all these guys
all these guys hate gay people really
yes is that real can we
check the fact checker over there all
these guys i said it in
it's literally all this shouldn't be a
surprise no all these fundamental
christians
don't like gay people straight up
well maybe it's not that they just think
it's a statement
they disagree they think you're gonna go
to hell and that a lot of them think
that you're causing hurricanes
i've even heard that i mean like
straight up there but they do they think
these people were biologically created
like they weren't no they think it's a
choice
and they're choosing to go walk the
devil's path because they want to be gay
hello these are the people this is your
last name all right i can't definitely
he's a scumbag
sorry damn i was really going to make my
case go for it
no go argue it now no i dare you to
argue who's not with the gays
it's not with me so now that we've
covered that joel you've got to admit
that he looks like a lesbian
a little bit jonathan taylor thomas
he's handsome
actually there's a really funny snl skit
where kate mckinnon talks about the
first time she masturbated and knew she
was gay was jonathan taylor thomas
like she masturbated to jonathan taylor
thomas and that's when she knew she was
gay she because this is the first time i
knew i was like a lesbian because she
thought he was a girl oh there you go
yeah i think it was called like it was
on snl it was like some backstreet boys
parody
oh that's funny see thanks for packing
me up here
it was there are some where is he at now
i don't know
i showed you a picture of him now what
was my what is my [ __ ] biographer
he was on tool time what do i know
someone also emailed me
home improvement well you know no troll
time was the show within the
apologies apologies there's no salt on
these great fries
many more salts on these nuts
that didn't even make sense yeah i need
the tears
yeah i was going with the gay theme nuts
i i wish that um joe lawson would cry on
these fries
add some salt someone emailed me and
asked if they got a frenemy's tattoo do
they get free merch
there's no marsh oh it's not happening
anymore no it is but like what am i
going to give to them
when it comes out because they think
it's already people are already
interested it's all going to sell out
and they want to get the pizza in
advance
and i don't want to encourage someone to
tattoo their body with their logo
the merch is much cheaper than a tattoo
just
good but i think they're thinking like
it's going to sell out like because that
is the [ __ ] thing when you have
money and you're ready to buy stuff and
it already sells out
[ __ ] jaclyn hill i'm looking at you
she put a pallet on sale and it all sold
out 15 minutes before is on sale
there's some [ __ ] yeah marketing we
made that mistake once on teddy fresh
where we
we were just trying to get things up and
then we put it up like like 10 minutes
early just because it was ready
but that's messed up because there's a
lot of people that get there on time
i got so we don't do that anymore the
jaclyn hill one i was there like
it was it was it was something shady
with that one though i was there 45
minutes you don't like her
yeah but i knew this was going to be a
thing so i was like trying to get it was
something like mystery box or something
i was trying to get
the thing she was selling and it was
already sold out for and i was in line
for 45 minutes does some [ __ ] i put
it in my cart and it was out
good for her no it knows something
sketchy i think she i forget the theory
look at a drama channel
was that she marked it sold out
what could it possibly be i don't know
she's so boring to me like i literally
but you're there you are buying her [ __ ]
because i wanted to get the views with
like
jaclyn hill lipsticks or whatever she
had you know so i was like trying to be
that person i couldn't even get it what
if you actually liked it
oh yeah well would you just not make the
video
oh no would you make a shitty person i'm
not gonna just be like oh this is a good
[ __ ] no i probably would have been
like oh i got it
it's good and you would admit but it's
not because i saw her hairy lipsticks
and those had hair in them
mystery boxes are like this like
[ __ ] where they have like nothing
like like jeffree stars like expired
[ __ ] or whatever they put in a box and
then they're like here
here's a mystery box by it it's like
stuff that people didn't want
i don't know if it's expired but you
know what i mean it's can we turn this
into a drama channel though about
jeffrey and the jay hair right go ahead
i'm um
i'm just eating french fries i saw the
drama channel talk about this and now
obviously jeffrey's working with hair by
jay again which is like actually like
it's been like five days
yeah he's like okay he's fine now which
isn't really just a jab at like [ __ ]
your show whatever they blocked me on
everything which is kind of everything
but
i have a theory that i bet like wait
wait they both blocked you
yeah i literally can't see anything
because jeffrey by the way he made this
tweet he's like good morning to everyone
but that guy
that hair guy that said rude things
followed him and
literally five days later blocked you
followed him back
tagged him like they tagged him and
still did like today
i think you're right it's pretty much
him being like i can do the [ __ ] i want
yeah but my theory is he's always being
nice to me because of shane and my
friendship but now that me and shane are
like
like this but i also feel like since
they discounted all of shane's
merchandise on the killer merch and on
the website
i feel like they're distancing
themselves in some ways something must
have happened behind the scenes and so
like that's
well clearly nobody's buying it i mean
if it's been on his website how long ago
was that series
no but like merch they were making new
merch even though shane wasn't promoting
it like they kept coming out with merch
while shane was cancelled
it was really weird i don't know that
was my theory behind it i was just like
oh well they probably have like a
falling out too which honestly they need
to distance himself
i don't think shane is like the devil i
think he made a deal with the devil
which is jeffrey i think rylan's boring
as [ __ ] and just doesn't need a podcast
and i think that's it that's my triangle
take on all of them
he's so boring he tried to leak his own
nudes that he already leaked like years
ago and tried to make it the podcast
like [ __ ] i got leaked again no one
cares about you ryan you only get 145
000 views on a leak knew that you leaked
you five years ago
it's just him on all fours from the side
it's something yeah that shane posted
already it wasn't leaked shane posted it
years ago
and i think he's like wow guys i was
trending again like i brought my
channel doesn't shane only [ __ ] cats i'm
surprised that they even are
intimate that's why he's on all fours to
emulate a cat
dude you're masked off with shane i can
say anything now
he's disgusting and when i like find out
more [ __ ] about him not to like go on
the path did you watch the wallace video
yet i did yeah
that's the d'angelo wallace it was good
disturbing yeah
i didn't know how that stuff like i said
i blindly definitely no i understand
don't even blindly defend your friends
don't even blindly defend your family
because let me just put this around like
if it was like to moses when you said
that huh you're like don't blindly
defend your family you pointed right to
moses
no we're all good i'm just saying are
you that i'm just calling out what i saw
god
you felt that right she pointed at you
no he wouldn't blindly defend his family
he's really honest about his family you
know like whatever he's just open books
just probably you're calling
you're not no what i'm saying is i
wouldn't are you gonna drink that water
where'd that come from we brought it
down for you when in the very beginning
it's been there the whole time do you
remember the movie matilda where she
tried to tip over the water with just
her eyes and she's like
so can i drink your water can i drink it
first
no you have it you touch the rim i don't
want it anyway i ate the same burger i
ate
what no i bit from the back what are you
crazy
not about that i don't want that what
are you crazy
anyways i hope they distance themselves
for shane say shake he could still be
saved by jesus just
distance yourself from the devil
denounce it and that's it
jeffrey should distance himself from
society just go live in a cave
yeah make like like lamb it up disappear
make a glam cave out in the wilderness
oh take your money and your non-rented
house like you know that's all that you
have to boast about is you that you
don't rent your house like you have some
like no actually what he did say because
i was paying attention he said
i actually put a big down payment on my
house so my mortgage is low
so what jeffrey broke ass star said is
he
has a mortgage on his house oh the bank
owns your house yeah
[ __ ] loser you broke that joke yeah
he has a mortgage about putting a big
down payment down
so i don't must so my mortgages you're
still mortgaging [ __ ]
you're still broke bro take the l
take the m for mortgage loser
thing where people pick up people for
like renting houses is so insane to me
like i cannot that's
me so and like the greasy skin comment
all that stuff like that like
uh i'm not gonna be mean i'm just going
to hold myself back because like there's
20 21 trisha
2021 tristram you're better someone i
wish them well
hair by jake keep killing those wigs
like i hope the
three thousand dollars from your clients
i hope they go broke after spending on
all those [ __ ]
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa that's a 20 21. okay i hope that
get up
keep it 2021. i hope the angela wallace
makes a series on you
i hope he makes one about david i watch
the [ __ ] out of that boy
he seems like a david stan no yeah he
keeps it real
what are you angela's biggest fan right
now i just think it well
i am a fan but i think he keeps it real
that's this whole thing right he can't
be a stan of anyone
is that me i don't think he's a fan of
you he's not you're exploited
oh i think we're done wait you got
something else
no i'm sorry wait what what do you want
to talk about
i'm here i just thought we were out i'm
not i just had a dream but i'll tell you
about it later
tell me about your dream you clearly
came here with an agenda tell me about
your dream
we weren't friends anymore oh okay
was it a premonition or a dream i don't
know like i became like really like this
big time rapper
and i oh that's a yeah that didn't
happen
that definitely didn't happen what did i
just i feel like one day actually what
kind of rap
a wrap like gangster wrap i don't know
what kind of i wasn't rapping in my
dream
okay i thought but i i do have a
premonition that i'm like i feel like
i'm going to be like a jimmy fallon and
i'm going to just have to leave this
show and i feel bad because you're so
nice to me
you're going to move up you're going to
ascend
to late night and say ethan i'm sorry
and then we've had a good thing but i
have to leave you behind eventually
we're gonna have to part ways and when
when is that gonna happen and what's
gonna happen like i'll feel bad if
that's you like what if
you know what i mean i'm pretty content
i'm not looking to move up anywhere
i feel like that's a problem with me i'm
never content i always think i'm going
to be doing better and bigger things
so you're going to be your plans to be a
rapper because i don't see that you plan
to be late night i don't see that either
i think both
a rapping late night host yeah did
arsenio hall do that
you can be on the show forever no i
don't think so and i feel bad
i'd be very happy for you if you
ascended to uh like i'm the next post
malone that leaves you
i'm like oh i'm too famous for ethan bye
oh yeah that did happen with post
you think that's why i don't know why i
post never stop talking to me
when i see that i sleep your old vlogs
will pop up now because i like watch
them so they always pop up and i see i'm
like
this is crazy he like went to your
guys's show and stuff
oh and you're like such like i'm not i
would never say a bad thing about him
no i know but here's the thing like that
like me just being like i'm never
talking to you again bye
i mean on look so here's the thing about
post malone
on a personal level as someone i
consider like a close friend
it did it kind of it did hurt my
feelings
but on the other end i understand that
his life is so crazy and so fast-paced
and he's just surrounded by all these
people
all the time and he's his life is moving
so fast
that i understand i underst i understand
i don't hold any grudge what happened
how did it like
nothing happened did you like trying to
text him and you just like weren't
hearing back he like goes to gym
yes pretty much no that does hurt
you know who doesn't do that is adam
sandler he's had his same friend group
alan covert he's his executive producer
in all the movies he has all his little
look it's not like we grew up together
because i know post is really loyal to
like his friends
who we grew up with so it's like i'm not
i didn't like grow up with him you know
but we had like a really good friendship
and he was like
yeah i was the biggest you were like
bigger than him at the time so he's like
oh i got this little come up with like
h3 he was having his friends make out
with me too which was where i didn't
understand why
you guys were like in a private jet with
him no we were we were
we were like hey we were like very good
friends i think that's where my dream
came from because i was watching that
before i went to bed
and then i was like oh i also became
like a rapper and i like left you like
that was oh you were posting
it does make me a little sad because
like
yeah just because we were friends and
that's it i mean you have like a lot of
friends
no exactly oh you're like [ __ ] i lost
it's like friends but it's fine like i
said i don't have any and well
i have nothing but nice things to say
about the guy he's a sweetheart
and um you know i wish him well it's not
there's really no ill at all he's like
just got two i i i
it makes sense like he he became his
rise to fame like when i met him
he was like didn't even put out his
first album you know
and so i saw this gradual like uh road
this like crazy stardom not like
but he's like one of the biggest artists
in the country you know
so like he just he got kind of
more and more distant as he got more
famous
and i think it's just because his life
was just too fast-paced and crazy
he was working and he's
there's just like i don't know you're
like a sad teddy bear right now
your eyes are the thing is i don't i
don't want anyone to think ill of him
because i don't no we are pro post
malone on this podcast yeah maybe he'll
be the next bachelor on h3
i'm pretty sure no can you imagine
that'd be [ __ ] crazy who do you think
would be better post malone or papa john
as the bachelor
as much as i'd like to say papa johna i
don't think that we're in the right age
bracket for papa my mom would apply
she's single okay anyone else
what moses mom does all the moms battle
i don't see it can i say that i don't
know if we can bleep her out if i'm not
supposed to say it
sorry um well we have single moms out
there
he likes there'll be a lot of women that
would be very happy you're right
there's age-appropriate women i'm not
saying that but like i mean he's like
55 or some [ __ ] i mean it's just not our
demo
i think you'd be surprised
okay papa if you're out there or post
oh paul you need help finding a date can
i will screen them though because i'm a
female and i feel like
with peace and love your interns are not
the best at screening people
i will scream that i agree with you they
were awful
maybe it's good they didn't find anyone
that good because look maybe if they
found someone that was like kind of good
maybe this wouldn't happen
maybe just nobody good applied that's
what i kind of said but
i hear that no because there were people
who dm like i applied but never went on
the show and they were like
lawyers and doctors and i was like
where'd these people come from
listen just because they weren't
entertaining like a character
i think they were like i think they're
lying so like during that time i was
using my dms
and you were going over those things if
they were doctors and lawyers we would
have put them in i think they just
weren't as entertaining
listen some we absolutely put in because
they were entertaining because it's a
show i mean come on you have to expect
that
but we put in plenty of respectable
games there was not one there was like
18. these are the people that
no i guess it was ethan that was saying
this is our demo like these are the
people who wanted to date you so
i will i will reach out to my demo for
you papa john or post malone i will find
my
my picture for you oh it's a different
demo let's let's lower
our standards for the batch a little bit
let's say maybe
shredder who's that my dog dog daddy
oh my dog will apply he needs a friend
or a boyfriend
trevor's looking to [ __ ] he's not
looking for friends well i think my dog
is gay
can i say that i don't know i think he
is yeah i mean dogs soon don't seem to
care they're just
they'll hump anything they're just happy
with humping alfredo over here
yeah you made a whole big deal about it
homophobia okay that was like
brothers they're like first of all
they're not biologically related so
and shane pumped his cat you didn't care
about it then i did not know about that
you did it well he says he was joking
but i
i don't think so you heard the recording
let's not joke about bestiality or
anything with children
right that might be like crossing the
line right
i think we're done now
is there anything else so you have no
other friends
i have a few friends i don't want to
name them yeah i have a few friends but
what do you do you do you see them or
you just talk on the phone or text your
heart we text
and sometimes we hang out during like
not that much honestly maybe a few times
are they your age yeah they're all my
age you talk to your brother a lot
i mean i talked to him i have like a
family chat with my family we all talk
there
so you don't just call him no your
brother seemed very normal and very
he's a great guy i love my brother you
should be friends with him
okay look he's my brother i mean he's my
brother
my sister's my only girlfriend that i
have yeah some people have that
relationship
and my brother's my brother it's not
like you know
i feel like this is a good podcast i
feel like next week
our physical can we announce that we're
doing a physical yeah yeah we were
supposed to do it today but
for some reason whatever happened to
adam and eve and my truth or dare how'd
it go did you were you squirting and
stuff
no it was for youtube i had to put up
the sponsored video for youtube
oh it has to be up on mondays by like 10
and i didn't get it in the past
your only fans i never hear about it
these days i try to be more low-key
because like we got approached to be on
a tv show for our wedding
so i'm trying to like not be so like
wait a tv show for your wife i shouldn't
say it because now they're gonna know i
do only fans i try and keep it like low
key that i'd like to do that how did
they not know that that's like one of
them because i deleted it all off my
like twitter and stuff like any sort of
like trace of it
but i'm saying if they know who you are
they know that that's what you probably
know but
uh it's like a reality show it's about
our wedding like seasons are you like
bridezilla is it bridezilla no but it's
a chain it's a
not a chain what are those so do you
have a season or an episode
uh well it's both it's hard to like
describe it you're gonna be
more than one episode like it'll air in
the summer but then our wedding is not
till the winter so they come back for
like the
like there's like i see i see you're no
it's not bradzilla i saw yourself
rightzilla
i'm not gonna tell you because i don't
want to like jinx it because it's not
like for sure but the interview how does
it work do they pay you do they help
with the wedding like how does it how do
they make it worth your time
really obvious like you gotta pay for
everything so like
so you just look you just think it would
be fun for them to show i think they
give you money they did offer like
this really like low amount yeah like
literally it's like a thousand dollars
is it gonna be a pain in the ass to
involve some weirdos in your wedding
like it's already stressful enough i
think it's more like
we were talking about like you said you
were offered to be like a mr beast
burger i think it's more just like
the coolness of it like we have a tv
show about our wedding yeah
it's cool i watch it you'll be in it
i'll be in it if you come to the wedding
if you want i'm coming to the wedding
and i'm going to be in front of the
camera so i'm going to follow them
around and make sure that i'm starting
the [ __ ] show
i'm like excuse me we have a show
together my name is lutheran klein
i have a comment to make i did do an
interview with a really i don't know
what it is lately but so many people are
coming to me this huge magazine just an
interview with me and i can't i don't
want to say it yet because it comes out
in march and oh my god nobody cares
about me you're right you are going to
leave me behind nobody approaching me
for interviews and [ __ ]
oh my god you're going to be a rapping
talk show and leave me behind and stop
answering my calls like post malone no
theirs is really i'm going to trauma i'm
trying my eating
there's a really big magazine that
wanted to interrupt me that's true
it's not gay if i eat this so don't you
can't eat that one eat the one that
sounds like call me daddy
daddy daddy anyways the point is they
asked me about you and our podcast oh
they did oh thank god
but towards the end of the interview did
they not email you because they said
they have to fact check everything like
we have to reach out to everyone you
talk about
in the interview really would they ask
you about me
um it wasn't anything crazy they were
just like
they like you have a podcast
they're coming to do a photo shoot at
our house like this week like it's a big
thing
well i don't want to jinx it because
paper magazine was gonna do a whole
feature on me for break the internet and
they shot at my house they did the photo
shoot they did the interview
and then the transgender video came out
and they were like uh
so i don't want it like jinx this one's
bigger than paper magazine though this
one's bigger in my opinion
what mm-hmm yeah
okay i'm on i was shocked i was like and
it's like a legit credible magazine that
talks about like
like i have political figures on the
cover and i don't think i'm on the cover
i think i'm just
are you time person of the year no
but i was really like i said i don't
think i know i'm not the cover i i
like a feature in it if you go and
become a rapping taco show
can i be the pathetic guy on the couch
next to you
like jason on views i want to be the
pathetic guy on the couch
everyone's like this is a visual
representation of jason's ten percent
i'll just laugh super loud and be like
act like i'm happy to be there even
though i hate you
they have the it's like just him and his
three assistants being so boring and
jason being creepy and like david thinks
he's a talk show because he has money
it's like no you're not sorry baby
you're just not
people watched it people liked it got a
lot of views you know what's called
views
wait what oh because they're all obvious
yeah i'm just saying people liked it
they watched i didn't watch it so i
don't know but
there's only four minutes on youtube i
was i don't understand i just pulled it
up why is it seven minutes long
yeah that's all they put on there i
don't know he cut it down a little
obviously insecure
did you say how they stole from us how
would that be david dobrik stole our
frenemy logo branding you said
you pointed it out i thought it was
funny but it's just okay
don't steal our branding the the what is
it what do they steal
it's just the color it's just two these
two colors or no
no it's it's on the yeah it's the logo
it's the logo color
nice try did you notice now they're
starting to do video podcasts because
frenemies is so
popular well i have been doing this for
a while just
so you know the video podcast right but
i don't think it's like been banging i
think you had a little bit of a low
slump for a year and then it kind of got
banging at him you know what
i can't even dude frenemies is off the
[ __ ] rails my whole career has been a
low slump so there's no shades
i always i still only get 100 000 views
on my videos so like i'm very fortunate
dude
you got to be kind of low-key happy when
drama goes down because you
make long-ass videos with a billion
mid-rolls and i know you're getting paid
i'm really not now oh yeah i was
watching that video about ab
and it was like mid-roll mid-roll oh
stop it thank you babe i do not put it
in there i do not
okay you're right youtube but isn't that
nice now you don't have to be like i
wasn't me
i should stop do you know how if i
didn't put it in automatically on our
podcast we'd have like a hundred mid
rolls
let's do it and maybe i should because
[ __ ] it i'm trying to get that
money because let's face it trish is
gonna outgrow my [ __ ]
sloppy ass and i gotta capitalize while
i can no you know my goal is to lose a
bunch of weight so i can get like weight
loss brand deals and be like really
because if i lost 100 pounds i'd be huge
but also i can't do it but if i did it
would be so big i'd be on people
magazine
it's not people magazine that i wanted
something else bigger bigger than people
yeah
and they don't care about my like me
losing weight or chubby
chubby chaser usa i don't know chubby
jason bbw
once told me that i was too chubby he
groped me and he's like wow
you gained weight and i was like oh i
never got invited back to the uh
playwood mansion after that that sounds
like the kind of stuff
he's like hey listen no fat people
allowed
no literally yeah literally they
wouldn't serve me food i remember they
had like chefs and i was
there for something he literally goes no
food for fatty i swear
so i went on for sunday fun days i have
pictures of me at the mansion and i
would always get quesadillas and
smoothies when i was there i was like
you know i was like i was tiny i was
like maybe 140 back then i'm like 220
now
and which i know you said on the age
three i was like okay 220 body slamming
but i didn't you i told you that
you said you're 220 and i said you think
i'm not skinny
oh you're more than two i love it okay i
went down a little bit but anyways
um beside the point no but when i went
up to the chef like i would go every i
went for maybe like three months to the
playboy mansion every sunday for their
like thing
and like the last sunday the day he said
i was getting fat um i had gone up like
hours before to ask them to hey can i
get my case dm a berry smoothie
and they're like we're not allowed to
serve you food anymore and everyone else
had it
i talked to him it was wild back in the
day yeah and then he like it wasn't even
that long ago but she used to be wild oh
it was like 2007. it was a while ago
no food for fatty who literally went to
the kitchen and said don't feed trisha
anymore she's too fat and it came from
half like they say it's direct orders
from half like
he literally went down to say and
there's like maybe 30. did you work
there why did you hear you were working
no no no i was trying to like be a
girlfriend like the way to be like a
girlfriend like that was like my goal i
was never going to happen
you wanted to [ __ ] you yeah there was
like 30 or 40 girls on sundays maybe
even less maybe like how many of them
were [ __ ] who
i don't know i never did oh you don't i
was like the ugly one
i always wondered how many of those
girls you fought i'm sure i don't think
you can
if you read the books about the ex
playmates i think he only can have sex
like once a week i don't think he gets
it up like
this because he's so old but back in the
day you must have
like can you like how it's kind of hard
i think it's so weird that like that was
fine
like this guy literally had a mansion
with a harem and he would cruise around
in a bathrobe and just like
yeah totally women who's that guy that's
trying to be like him now with the beard
and he's just like dan blizzaria
what why i hate him such a weirdo such a
loser what is his deal like why what's
his thing why is he trying to
i'm pretty sure with peace and love and
with lots of um
maybe you shouldn't say it if you're
saying with peace and love like don't
follow it up
if you're gonna say something that could
get you in trouble well that's like a
legal
thing oh with peace and love allegedly
your honor
this is not defamation with peace and
love was issued before the defamatory
comment
this is my hunch is that he does illegal
[ __ ]
or super shady money yeah super shady
[ __ ]
he seems like the type of guy that would
like i wonder if he runs his houses like
give predatory loans you know what i
mean
that kind of dude who gives like quick
money loans and [ __ ] like that oh
can i tell you when we bought the house
i had to pay off all my quick money
loans because i used to do those all the
time back in the day like literally like
i would take out loans like at what were
they like what was the place speedy cash
and i i got a 700 loan in like 2012 or
something i don't know
you left that open i left it open i
still owed 8 000
and i've been paying it every month
since 2012 oh yeah that's why it's so
[ __ ] up because the interest is so
high
you could pay them back 800 a month and
you're not even getting to the princess
i'm not joking
i think i i've like paid them like
thirty five thousand dollars for my 700
loan that should be illegal i had like
three how many like four open loans and
i had to pay them all out before we
could get our home loan
so how much did you pay off for how much
did you get i think we paid off
like paying off meaning i owed 30 000 to
all these different places
and i think twice did 700 at one place i
think i did 1200 at another and maybe
1500 at the other place
not a good deal and i probably spent
60 000 to each one so probably 108 000
over the years to all of them
for three thousand dollars that should
be [ __ ] illegal
the fact that that [ __ ] is legal blows
my mind and i was paying like yeah
thirty thousand
percent uh interest rate that's normal
they should tell you they never told me
i guess it's in the fine print but who
reads that
well i guess you should assume you're
gonna get [ __ ] if you go to some
i thought maybe something but you don't
expect that that's why it should be
illegal
you expect all paying back double maybe
triple not like 30 times or more 100
times it's insane and that those it was
a wow
name one but speedy cash quicken loans
like i forgot the other ones some other
things we never heard of i can't even i
can't remember
you have to be a real specific funding
you have to be a real [ __ ]
soulless oh i can't say that
bleep that dan believe it
um yeah don't do loans don't hang out
damn pulsarian it's not a good luck
nobody cares you're not hugh hefner and
you're not cute by the way he pays those
girls to hang out with him it's like not
that cool
serious and they're not even like
playmates also it's like cool you're
rich and a bunch of girls want to be
around you it's like
cool dude yeah epic
so we don't like dan blizzarian for sure
for sure i don't like the third co-host
on impulsive i used to love that show
and i can't watch it
well thank you finally you come around
and took him to threatening my life
no it's the third co-host that gets me
what about mike you like mike
i don't really like him but he is
entertaining like he's just like it's
like me people think people like
like like to like hate me you know like
at times can we not promote other
podcasts
oh yeah especially ones that have
threatened my life
people thought in the comments that you
should have came in for me but i
asked you did you really take it are you
like losing sleepwalking it doesn't
matter they find your life what do i
need to lose sleep for
for you to care about any of my problems
just glazed over ours like when your
friend was on their podcast and they
mentioned in front of me and
they just kind of like glazed but they
all shot each other it looks like oh you
mean when tim dillon was like i like
ethan klein he's funny
no he said something like don't be on
frenemies talk arguing with trisha
paytas
remember oh it's tim dylan yeah and they
were just like they didn't say anything
that glazed over but they all like shot
each other looks like what were they
thinking
like are we are we like you know because
like david can't mention my name like no
one in the world
yeah they're like don't mention that
well clearly because anyway whatever
[ __ ]
[ __ ] douche and his dad's a [ __ ]
criminal
his dad well you know the son should not
suffer the sins of their father so
what are you talking about greg paul gp
coming at you
his dad used to live in a van outside
jake paul's house and
and he had a leaked i swear to god
somebody hacked his phone
and his dad was having sex with like
these little hussies that were with jake
like do you think jake paul just set it
up
i don't know but he was definitely on
sex with young girls there was one of
jake's
uh videos where his dad was making out
with a girl maybe she'd be friends with
jason ash
oh yeah they'd be him and dr phil and
jason nash
we're off the rails guys wait remember
when jake paul showed up to post
mullen's house going full circle
yeah how come like he doesn't get
canceled like how come no one's like oh
this guy's awful like don't show up to
people's houses you dumb [ __ ]
i mean he did get dragged pretty well
did he i don't remember it so i just
thought
yeah hated where is jake paul he's gone
now he moved to like florida to become a
boxer which is like laughable
one last thing and then we can wrap it
up but um how much
would it take for us to have a wrestling
match
it's too much like andy hoffman style no
like any common wrestled women
it's too much like touching and stuff
okay it's not a sexual sport
i know but it's just that it makes me
uncomfortable you'd rather do the
acrobatic gymnastics
oh yeah i actually have a video that let
me pull that up because i don't know
what you're talking about i really want
to do this
can we start with the monkey bars i'm
pretty strong oh so next week is our
physical fitness chest are someone like
testing us are we just like doing a
pull-up
yeah um no ian's ian's gonna conduct a
whole
regiment for us are you training no
i'm not training either i thought about
it i'm like no yeah
i want it to be real and also i don't
want to exercise
so don't worry exercise you train more
than i do i get winded going up
there already making excuses i'm
preparing i think i may have
overestimated my
strength definitely my mom and sister
are like you can't do a paw patrol
there's no
way you can do it you're too tough
you're too top-heavy thank you
it's just a matter of fact there's not
like a compliment okay here we go
oh you think we could roll around in
these beds in these [ __ ]
curtains the curtain yeah
[Music]
do you see this girl weighs like 80
pounds it's about strength
core strength arm strength do you think
you could climb a curtain like this girl
yes
but we can do a duet i guarantee you
will not even be able to hold yourself
up even one end can you look up zendaya
and zac efron
i just want to show you how beautiful it
could be like if we nailed it in
practice like we could do
a really cool type in zendaya's and i
guess muted so you don't get copyright i
don't know how this works on here
yeah we commuted it i like looking at
people's like okay
there that one oh wow okay this could be
this could be us
okay fast forward a little bit as if
efron ever been in a good movie
this one greatest showman i thought you
said you hated it i literally
i literally just asked you and you said
it was awesome i like the tick tocks
okay that doesn't mean the movie not
this part go to the like that go to the
we're not doing that like that
okay calm down so you don't think i'm
like trying to be like let's [ __ ]
make out
this part we're gonna do and watch when
he comes he comes up and then you kind
of oh i can do that look she's falling
that's not her that's a body double i
could do that no they totally trained
you would [ __ ] hit the earth like a
bag of [ __ ] watch they're gonna go
together they're gonna go up together
this is oh
iconic we can do that i'm not doing that
with you
with a safety net look first of all
it's way too intimate no you don't have
to be close like that watch but you just
do this kind of stuff
watch you're so far apart what you're
shooting do you think you could do this
are you out of your [ __ ] mind yeah i
want to do it you can't even hold your
up on your own weight with one arm i
totally can't oh my god you can train up
in san luis obispo
dude training is one thing you got we
got to lose like 150 pounds
i think we could do it if we lose 150
pounds a piece
i think a hundred maybe 100 okay 100
yeah sure if we each lose 100 pounds
then we can do this that would put me at
120.
me too i'll be 130 then if i lost 100
pounds
okay okay cool we'll never do it thank
you you said it here if we lose 100
pounds
yeah i can't tell if you're serious you
think you can actually do i actually do
because that you can do
some momentum going yeah you got to go
up to get the momentum first
and by the way your momentum is running
straight into the earth
it's a direct line
all right well i think
okay we did it we reached the end okay
so no one else should reach out to you
for david interviews you're done
you're closing that chapter i mean feel
free to reach out but like
you can't i'll ch but you know it's just
like like i just think that if i keep
talking about it it's people are not
gonna
are gonna stop taking it seriously can
you talk about it without making it the
title because i do think it's
important you give people voices where
they feel scared to share other other
places
but i get it no i can't i can't i can't
keep doing it i'm not it's not my
i'm not the david dobrik guy you know i
can like you said if people have stories
come out and say it
and then maybe i'll see it and talk
about it but the thing about
big nick and seth these were both people
who tried to share their stories
but didn't get the attention that they
deserved
and these are also two people that were
like intimately involved in the vlog
squad like they're
have the most trustworthy not not that
this person's not charged
but like the most let's say credible
because they're in the videos there's
like so much there you can't really even
like what seth said you can't there's no
two ways about it right
right well i'm glad that you did it for
real that was that it just felt like
a relief when you hear like other people
finally being like maybe trisha was like
not like it's just like this like the
relief where it's like finally people
are seeing something and not calling me
crazy or obsessive or like weird or
freak or like bitter as abe said i'm not
bitter that i'm not in the group
i literally left it with you know
blazing saddles
yeah and by the way i like i spoke to
seth and nick a little bit afterwards
and they were both like super
they both expressed feeling like super
relieved that they were able to
yeah get their message out to a
receptive well you can do
i mean like they i think everyone has
the same kind of like not we're
definitely not trying to cancel he's not
going to be canceled but i think like
by the way i don't i don't even think
david's a bad guy i think he's a bad guy
well you know so i don't know him really
i don't think he's gonna get canceled
i'm not trying to cancel him it's gonna
be
that's not even the goal like he won't
be careful like look at mel gibson still
throwing i'm not challenging i don't
want arriving
i love well i don't love woody well i
don't know on the other hand support him
oh there's like a documentary coming
about woody allen
[ __ ] and his and his
wife slash daughter-in-law or
step-daughter
i still love woody allen vlog it's
coming out on like hbo too
it's like serious [ __ ] it's not like
some lifetime [ __ ]
just don't marry your stepdaughter dude
the woody allen [ __ ]
is so freaky didn't he like adopt her
when she was like three
it was me a pharaoh's adopted daughter
when she was three but she would he
raised her
mm-hmm he raised this girl from
oh from nine maybe like five or
something because me a fair adopted at
first then they got married
so he's living in the same house so he
raised his little girl from five
and then got intimate with her when she
was like 16. sorry
yeah that's [ __ ] up
okay even if you're going to even if you
want to [ __ ] your s
your stepdaughter let's wait till she's
18.
i maybe just don't if you need someone
at nine you don't really need to [ __ ]
them when they're an adult
i mean i agree with you i'm going to
agree with you on that one
okay just you know there's other people
to have sex
the story is it's incredible i mean yeah
how are you gonna [ __ ] your own
stepdaughter and then marry her
yeah they're still married though one
more thing and i promise we can go keep
saying this but like is the h3 podcast
tick tock you guys running that
yes how come there's no blue check mark
it looks like a fake account it's new
it's just a new account you thought
everyone was getting a ton of views from
our clips so you're like well we might
as well put them up there well we
thought about it for a long time and
then
um we have a guy who does clips for us
yeah the clip's like bomb
and he's really good he's like the best
and so he's like
he has a ton of clips because we've been
doing clips on instagram and facebook
already yeah i love that i love when he
sent me clips
and so yeah he's the one that does the
clip so he just started posting post and
posting a tick dog and it's like
dude teddy fresh name change is that
like a joke no
that changed and you had no idea how
happy so what happened okay
i'm my name on tick tock is ethan klein
h3
i woke up yesterday and it was teddy and
i saw all the comments
it was like why is it teddy first it's
like what happened with teddy fresh
and then i saw my [ __ ] tick tock name
now is teddy fresh
how and so i realized what happened so
i wanted to make a teddy fresh tick tock
account and then there's a teddy fresh
account that's inactive like totally
inactive
dead like no followers no posts so i
wrote to
a tick tock or like someone i know who
knows tick tock and i said hey can we
get the teddy fresh account
for our business and he says i'll see
what i can do that was like two weeks
ago
and so i woke up yesterday and they
switched my [ __ ] personal
account to teddy fresh i was like how
the [ __ ] was that
the howl that's like so far you're
trying to create a scandal you're trying
to be like ryan just creating a scandal
no
i don't want to be you don't want to be
teddy bears you are teddy fresh
no i want to be ethan klein i'm not
literally look like the teddy fresh logo
you look like a teddy bear i think
that's a compliment
yeah yeah you look like a teddy bear in
a good way oh thank you is it not
designed after you
i thought it was made in like you're
like that's your thing you were
makes me uncomfortable tigers it's
cringy oh it was designed after your
likeness though
not after my likeness no but you love
teddy bears no
stop i don't want to talk wait no what
is this embarrassing oh no i want to
know
[Music]
[Applause]
i need to know this so me and it's so
crazy
why are you making me do this i feel
like it's cute actually i feel like it's
going to be a cute story not an
embarrassing story
it's both it can't be worse than your
proposal pooping story
no okay so let's hear it it's just too
cutesy and it's embarrassing
i love it because you guys aren't cutesy
enough not not judging we love you
just not not [ __ ] in front of you
here cute scene
you know what i mean we both call each
other
ted that's like our pet names for each
other
i asked you something names and you
didn't tell me and so then
well we were brainstorming ideas
and so we were just thinking of like
teddy b we were trying to think of like
what would be like a logo
and also the other thing is like what's
a website domain that's available
and so we're trying a bunch of stuff
it's so weird the teddy fresh
with the teddy bear logo and the domain
teddy fresh was unclaimed after all
these years which i thought was
i mean it's very exciting because it's
like teddy brush random
yeah yeah but on all the other social
medias it was taken so i thought that
was
wow like the instagram name i had to buy
from some [ __ ] guy for ten thousand
dollars
ten thousand i was trying to get it from
him for
so long and eventually i was like dude
whatever i'll just pay you whatever the
[ __ ] because yeah he saw your success
so you called each other ted not teddy
both
did you get pissed when united airlines
started calling themselves ted and
you're like the [ __ ] that was our thing
they're called ted i didn't know that
what about ted talks are you like oh
that's our thing
uh teddy fresh's brother ted you know
what's funny the teddy
oh actually i don't talk about the other
thing but why because
it's too it's like personal info thing
never mind but um
um yeah we were in a we're in a legal
battle with ted
talks no i'm kidding ah i like tea
yeah we're suing them no why don't you
sponsor ted talks
i don't think those people are
interested in teddy fresh
they actually asked me to do a ted talk
too stop about what
they did you got me you just did it to
me
i was like what the [ __ ] would you give
a ted talk about
squirting could you imagine proper
squirting technique
i made one million dollars and all i had
to do was drink a bottle of water and
piss
so it is piss no i know you would love
that all right let's stop this is yeah
it always goes over the rails
territory all right so next week
physical fitness we're going to have
that this is going to be fun i should
get another spray tan maybe i should be
tan for that
can you ask her to go extra hard on your
hands only give me some extra grip
i should get her to could she come to my
house and just tam my hands
she would love it like i'm totally not
even kidding 800 followers probably love
the shout out
i'm not shouting her out oh yeah you
don't love shout outs to you i'll pay
her
what do i gotta shout everybody out i'll
pay you one of my [ __ ] shout out moms
i have money let me pay you my least
favorite thing like stupid i want you to
pay and then also be like tag us
no like you can't even pay me enough for
the tag but also i paid you that's not
how that works
i don't i don't like the tax i have
currency i have currency too
i do current we are living in the
society we're money
for service don't do any [ __ ] no
[ __ ] with shout outs
money for service how do you charge
other people money
save money for service so you're not
doing the ring shout outs for free rings
they pay you yeah of course oh i thought
you got like free doorbells from them
i did but it was part of the sponsorship
they also paid you cash
yeah oh so you took the free and you got
the cash yeah
but i did buy they only sent me like two
i was like can i get more they're like
no really so i had to i bought like four
more so i did do it
oh okay cool h3 code h3
bye guys
[Music]
you